things are getting pretty wild my
friends very wild Greg Abbott governor
of Texas says that 10 other states have
deployed National Guard to Texas to
defend the border and we're are hearing
reports that private citizens in various
capacities are makinging their way to
Texas there are many people prominent uh
personalities saying do not go to Texas
fearing Another January 6th type
incident I don't know what's going to
happen I think this one should be left
up to Greg Abbott and the National Guard
and law enforcement and should be done
through all the legal channels they're
going through if National Guard are
being deployed I think it's probably a
safe bet to say private citizens
shouldn't go anywhere near this in in in
reference to any kind of conflict I
can't I can't you know tell people what
they should or shouldn't do if you're
private citizen you can go where you're
allowed to go but I definitely think
it's important to say there's a lot of
danger right now and Greg Abbott is
walking a fine line and he's walking the
right line and the the best way this
this this is carried out is if Greg ebot
can handle this with the assistance of
other states but uh a lot of wild news
breaking all of this down there's also
reporting that the border of Patrol
Union said they stand with Texas so I'm
I'm having trouble corroborating a lot
of this I want to be careful it's just a
reporter I'm seeing on on on X we'll
talk about that plus Donald Trump has
been ordered to pay $83 million to egene
Carroll for defaming her uh so they say
things are getting absolutely crazy and
of course my friends I I I don't really
know how to say this I'm just going to
Ben Shapiro is the number one rapper in
the world right now all right all right
all right let's be fair it's not it's
not absolutely true and correct to say
that but on iTunes
worldwide Ben Shapiro and Tom McDonald
have released a song and that in which
Ben Shapiro wraps one of the verses and
uh they're and the top of the iTunes
charts now a lot of people point out
sales aren't you know there it's not a
lot of competition on iTunes we've done
something similar however the song just
went up and so this is this is this is
massive to reach this level in one day
and if everybody buys the song on Amazon
or iTunes it is entirely likely that Ben
Shapiro could be as of next week not
next week but so throughout this next
week they'll they'll track the charts
and then the following Tuesday we'll
release the Billboard charts across the
board Ben chapiro will probably be a
billboard charting hip-hop artist and
rapper because already the amount of
sales they have so we'll talk about that
before we get started head over to cast
brew.com buy the best cup of coffee
you'll ever have we got Appalachia kns
that's everybody's favorite rise with
Roberto Jr you can join the C Brew
Coffee Club when you buy from Cas Brew
not only are you getting the best cup of
coffee you'll ever have and I really do
think you better try Appalachia kns cuz
we have sold out of our ground and K
Cups of Appalachia nights they're we're
restocking as fast as we can whole beans
still available but apparently this
stuff's so good people are buying it
like crazy but you're also going to be
supporting the show we sponsor ourselves
and we're working on physical locations
we have got a coffee shop currently
under construction and second floor
private club where we're going to be
doing Live Events potentially once a
month we're still working out the
details but this means those in the
Martinsburg West Virginia area or
anywhere close enough the on to drive
down we're going to have members only
live shows and it's going to be a lot of
fun support cast brewcast brew.com but
also my friends head over to facts
withth ben.com that's fact like fawi
ben.com and you can pick up Tom McDonald
xben chapiro fax and uh you can help
make Ben Shapiro the number one rapper
in the world I want to stress this is
not a sponsored spot we are not paid to
say this I want look I'm a big fan of
Tom McDonald and I'm a big fan of Ben
Shapiro though I have criticisms of Ben
Shapiro's commentary I think a lot of
you you do I respect the work as for Tom
McDonald I think he's amazing and I
definitely want to see Tom succeed in
the music industry and when I talk about
the work we do in music and how we want
to smash our way into the Billboard
Chart rankings the same applies for our
friends who make music as well which
includes the guys over at based records
five times August and right now with Tom
McDonald releasing a song with Ben
Shapiro you know we love shouting out
Tom McDonald but when I heard that Ben
shapir was going to rap I they no one
asked me to do this I said I the love of
God can we make Ben appear with a number
one rapper in the country and it's just
not only an there's a great message in
the song with what the lyrics are
themselves but the
troll I'm sorry I just if there's
anything if there's anything I could buy
like if there's anything I could wish
for right now aside from Justice on the
border right but as a cultural Endeavor
we can all do right now as just
something fun it's to go to facts withth
ben.com and buy the song to support Tom
McDonald and Ben Shapiro and again we're
not sponsored to say this they did not
no one asked us to do this I asked them
to do it and they said we will shout you
out before we get started I also want to
give a shout out to Orin McIntyre who
says on Twitter the year is 2024 Texas
leads a coalition of over 20 States who
oppose the federal government Taylor
Swift is the biggest name in
professional football Ben Shapiro is the
number one rapper in the country it's
only January welcome to 2024 ladies and
gentlemen smash that like button become
a member over at
timcast.net talk about this and
everything else is the great Larry Elder
Tim thank you so much for having me hey
if I'm can be the black face of white
supremacy then Ben Shapiro can be the
number one rapper in America I have a
brand new book it's called as goes
California my mission to rescue the
Golden State and I'm breaking some big
new Breaking some big news on your show
I called the CEO tell him I was going to
be on your show turns out he's a big fan
of yours he said you tell Tim any of his
viewers want a free copy of your book
have them go to oldglory bank.com open
up an account and when you get your your
debit card in the mail you will get a
free copy of Larry Elder's book as goes
California a $25 value oh right on
what's the book about it's about
California how messed up it is why I ran
for the recall election and at the time
I was thinking about running for
president later on I did and about why I
want was running and what I would do if
I became president we got to talk about
that especially with what's going on in
Texas these other states speaking up as
goes California yep all right excited to
have you here man I appreciate it my
pleasure we got Hannah Clair brimo
hanging out hey I'm Hannah Clair I'm
a writer for cnr.com it's a really cool
team you should follow them timcast
newws on Twitter and Instagram Phil's
here hello I am Phil leonti lead singer
of the heavy metal band All That Remains
uh very failed musician anti-communist
and
counterrevolutionary and what's up guys
I'm filling in for Serge it's Kellen I'm
wearing my Texas hat uh with all the
news going on and the today's culture
War I thought it was appropriate so uh
let's get to it Tim here we go the first
story from americanmilitaryu
video Texas prepared for standoff with
Biden 10 States send troops and launch
enforcement to the Border Governor
Abbott told former Fox News host Tucker
crosson Friday that 10 states have
already sent National Guard troops or
other law enforcement members to the
southern border to Aid Texas in the face
of growing pressure from President Joe
Biden's Administration to allow border
patrol agents to remove razor wire
barriers the state installed to deter
illegal immigrants from pouring into the
state during Friday's interview with
Carlson Abbott said he would be
surprised if any of the 25 Republican
states that have pledged to support his
state did not send additional assistance
quote there have been about 10 states so
far that have sent National Guard or
other law enforcement abot said they are
now joined together with us and this is
a fight for the future of America now I
don't know what's currently going on
news is happening very uh it's changing
rapidly with what's happening on the
border today was the deadline the Biden
Administration was supposed to do
something apparently I've seen some
people uh spreading a rumor that there
was some uh they said okay today's the
deadline but then they said something
like 6 p.m. and I have not heard
anything just yet some people are saying
there's very little information coming
out because something is actually going
on behind the scenes but I don't know
for sure part of me wants to believe
because of normaly and optimism bias
this will all blow over but considering
Ben Shapiro is the number one rapper in
the world I think it's more likely to
just erupt in the most absurd way
imaginable I think it's important to
point out that at one time Democrats
spoke like Donald Trump did about
illegal immigration and about the
borders um people like uh Chuck Schumer
uh people like Harry Reid after the
first bombing of the World Trade Center
he even Harry Reid even talked about how
the 14th Amendment is interpreted to
confer citizenship to an illegal alien
uh who has a baby on American soil he
thought that was wrong they even use the
term illegal alien people like that said
this kind of stuff Amy kachar said it
Diane Feinstein said it now all of a
sudden they've done a 180 and anybody
who feels the way Donald Trump feels is
a
bigot no it's crazy I I think our uh
country forgets that at one point we
were willing to talk openly about the
ills of illegal immigration as a country
became afraid of being called racist and
then we said it's okay we'll just leave
the Border open and now everyone else
pays the the the cost of it both
financially and psychologically it
really detracts from the American Spirit
if we have a class of people in this
country who are not actually a part of
it and we say to the legal immigrants
the things that you did to get here the
sacrifices you made were actually for
nothing because you don't get the
benefits of cross I think it's less that
people are concerned about being called
racist and more that the Democrats
realize this is a big voting
constituency uh and they wanted to
change the electorate because they were
losing election
America was a 50-50 Nation but you bring
in a bunch of people who are going to
pull the lever for the Democratic party
they assume and all of a sudden you
you're guaranteed a governing Coalition
for Democrats in in the future that's
why they're doing this yeah it's it's
pull the Lev or just change the Census
Data but it's it's it gives them
congressional seats and electoral votes
of course the argument that that that
you hear them make to the average person
that's say like low politically low
political information is that the you
mean stupid people I'm trying to be nice
um is that our our uh unfunded
liabilities are going to destroy the
economy and we need to have people come
in to work because we do not have
replacement uh levels of of having
babies and
stuff and I think that there is some
some validity to the argument which is
why I think it's convincing I think that
that gets to I think that that makes
makes enough of an argument to convince
people that are again that are low
information what do you think is the
best way to convince them because I talk
to people that just they'll see
stuff even if the argument have validity
that U population getting older unfunded
pension liabilities so-called
entitlements so we need to bring in new
people in order to make them contribute
so that these people can get their full
benefits it has still has to be legal we
have to know who they
are what they're here for what their
intentions are you just can't come
across the border and go okay well
you're you're solving our unfill
unfunded pension liability problem it's
ridiculous and and I I got to say before
I would ever accept that proposed
solution I would accept if you have
three babies you pay zero federal taxes
I'd love it yeah my my my only point or
the only point in asking that question
and the thing that I'm concerned with is
convincing people that the situation is
untenable convincing them that this is
actually a problem because I do believe
that most people don't pay attention you
know most people don't really watch the
news very closely and then when they do
they tend to listen to what the the
Talking Heads say and they assume that
that's the truth Michael malice talks
about you know when you tell the average
person that the news is lying to them
they what it's like you're you're being
told that the the meteorologist is lying
to you and he knows right most people
think the news is telling the truth how
and my concern is convincing them that
we actually do have a real problem and
so I want to know what what people think
the best way to you know to actually
to move the needle because the this is
it's coming to a head where we're where
it's possible that we could mem
ourselves into actual conflict like
everything is theater until someone
actually does something and anytime you
get dudes with guns in close proximity
with opposing interests there's a chance
for that and I don't want to see that
happen well Phil let's talk about the
original sin here the original sin is
Joe Biden he comes in and he literally
says essentially the borders are open
during the debate against uh uh Donald
Trump he said there's going to be a
surge to the Border he promptly reverses
every single one of the Trump policies
they gave us the most secure Border in
our history and I know that it is I'm
staying in a hotel where you guys send
me there whole bunch of DEA guys there a
border patrol guys there and I had
conversation with one right before I got
into the to come over yeah at at the
hotel I stay at where where you send me
yeah they had a whole bunch of uh border
patrol people staying there and I talked
to them told them where I was going they
knew who you were and um I said Donald
Trump often says that when he was
President we we had the most secure
Border in our history is that true and
there were two guys there they said
absolutely it was true and they said it
was like a a switch was turned on when
Joe Biden came in he stopped the stay in
Mexico program he resumed catch and
release uh the Mexicans took off the
25,000 people they had in their military
moov them elsewhere uh and uh uh the the
problem then exploded he said overnight
there was a illegal alien coming across
the border being interviewed by a woman
named Martha radit she's said long time
reported with ABC News and he and she
said to him if Donald Trump had gotten
reelected would you be here he said no
and she was shocked and he said why and
he said Joe Biden has given us piso
change the rhetoric change the policies
and that's why they're here so that's
the original sin and so Joe Biden should
have seen this coming you think
America's going to sit around and watch
millions of people coming across the
country and do nothing about it are you
are you serious and the reason why
they're basically asked for it the
reason they're coming to Eagle Pass is
because of the controversy mhm because
you have uh if they go to other places I
think lukeville is in Arizona they're uh
places where there's large there's a lot
of controversy you have leftist
organizations they know are prepared to
accept you and fight on your behalf to
enter whereas if they go to some random
you know open border like I should say
unprotected border area private property
or otherwise they could get shot you go
to Eagle Pass let the right and the left
fight about it and the border patrol
agents bring you in bring you to where
you need to go where someone gives you
money
uh but I'll say I don't I don't have a
particularly high opinion of border
patrol agents right now however should
that report be be correct from I think
it's from Colin rug that the border of
Patrol Union announced support for Texas
then I'm then I'm on board but CBP
agents have to stop facilitating the
human smuggling the I see a video of
them raising the razor wire to assist
human Smugglers those guys have
committed a crime they're just following
orders they're just following orders oh
all the more reason they should be in
prison they they're just following
orders they don't want to do this they
want to keep their jobs they're just
following ORD and and Phil to your point
they should be in prison to your point
uh it is becoming an issue uh in Iowa
it's the number one issue it's not even
a border state I've been traveling all
throughout Iowa they weren't talking
about this when I was there it's now
become the number one issue over um over
over inflation over the economy in in
Iowa and the most ingenious thing that
the uh Southern Governors did was start
sending these people to cities like
Chicago uh in New York and Martha
Vineyard because then it came to them
and all of a sudden now they're taking
this problem seriously or more seriously
than before
I have a friend uh good friend of mine
that was uh talking he's got a friend
that actually works at border patrol and
he isn't even like he's not even
convinced that they like I said he's not
even convinced there's a problem he's
like well my friend says that if they're
here illegally that they can that Texas
can just put them over the border and
and he says so they're this is actually
a show from uh you know from DeSantis
and a show from Abbot and I'm like I'm
pretty sure that these people are coming
and asking for Asylum and that's why and
that's the problem and they're being
processed in and they let them in they
give you a court date 3 4 years down the
road they don't show up in fact I asked
one of the guys today we have 8 million
illegal aliens in the country since uh
Joe Biden he said that number is
probably accurate I said how many of
them are going to be deported if and
when Donald Trump comes back he said I
don't see how we can possibly Rite them
up and get them out they're here they're
here for good I'm pretty sure uh we we
dealt with this when um what was the who
was the head of ice a few years back Tom
hman hman right
uh I'm pretty sure in his testimony
outright said it it doesn't matter if
they're seeking Asylum Crossing through
Asylum legally you must go to a legal
Port of Entry and make a declaration
that means the CBP agents who there's a
video of them opening a gate in the
Ballard fence and and waving them in and
these aren't the only instances again
they were just following orders so Tim
which is an excellent reason why they I
hold them 10 times more responsible than
I would if they were actually you know
uh uh the the you're you're saying
they're intentionally committing
felonies because they were told to does
not change the fact they committed
felonies well that's fair argument but
uh Joe Biden uh and Tom and mayorcas are
telling you with a straight face the
borders are secured no no Biden said the
border is not secure he said he said it
recently but before before before that
when myor said the borders are secured
he doesn't know what's going the the
press secretary confirmed that that she
thought the borders were secured I think
uh I completely agree uh Joe Biden
should be impeached over this and
convicted over this talk about
Insurrection I oh I mean yeah subverting
the law violation of article uh I mean
Greg Abbott says article 4 section 4 and
Article 1 Section 10 and so now he's
actively trying to stop the state from
defending itself yeah I think uh for
this Biden should be impeached and
convicted and following his impeachment
and conviction criminally charged along
with people in his administration that
being said the challenge we face right
now is the political barrier of we don't
want the Democrats to be able to sub out
Joe Biden at a time when Joe Biden is
like we want the people to vote to bring
in Donald Trump to solve the problem we
actually impeach and convict Joe Biden
they could bring in Michelle Obama or or
Gavin Nome and it's going to benefit
them and and the corruption not GNA not
going to happen Tim here's the deal the
reason Joe Biden uh is not going
anywhere if you can fog up a mirror it's
because the next person in line is not
it's not Gavin Newsome uh it's not
Michelle Obama
it's KLA Harris she wants to be
president I read a lot of black media uh
and they feel she's being picked on for
her so-called cackle they feel that Joe
Biden is given her thankless tasks like
getting to the bottom of the root causes
of illegal immigration uh and black
women are the most loyal part of the
democratic base and they will be furious
if she's Drop Kicked uh for anybody
other than a Michelle Obama and Michelle
Obama does not want the job she wants to
be loved she wants to be liked there's
nothing that suggest to me she has the
temperament I want to send her thank you
notes every Christmas for that she does
not have the temperament to be a
politician she she complained for eight
years about what it was like to be in a
fishbowl of being first lady what makes
you think she wants to be a politician
she likes to be wealthy and influ the
play all Trump supporters must send warm
thank you letters to Michelle Obama but
also include it's we would be upset with
you and we wouldn't love you anymore if
you ran for president so just keep it
where it is and we're good and and and
if uh Michelle uh Comm har a drop kick
for some white dude like uh mayor Pete
or Gavin Nome they will be led they
won't votee Republican they just won't
vote at all thereby guaranteeing whoever
we nominate will win they won't do that
it's a rocking hard way for Democrats
man so you live with the identity race
card you die with it
and that's why she's there she got
picked because she's a black female
she's still a black female by the way
she wanted to run for president she did
run and and and tell her to step aside
for Michelle Obama even if Michelle
Obama announced she kamla ran for da of
San Francisco she got elected she ran
for AG of California got elected and
reelected she ran for US senator got
elected and she was on the card with uh
with Joe Biden got elected she's never
lost election when she's been on the
ticket and there's nothing at all that
suggests to me that she's going to oh my
God I'm Inc confident I'll step aside
from Michelle Obama oh my God I'm Inc
confident step aside for gav not going
to happen unless they're uh she along
with Biden are impeached and convicted
and she's ineligible but what would she
I mean what is the timeline in that I
think it's more likely they just leave
Joe Biden where he is zero chance of
either them I I don't think they they
they would impeach they they may want to
honestly because how can you sub the KLA
Harris thing is a huge problem for
Democrats how do you they can't even so
how do you get Michelle Obama in without
both the back room and forward- facing
deals if they were uh so you know Roger
Stone said they're going to offer her a
supreme court seat kamla Harris and
she'll bow out I said no no no that
might solve the back room deal no they
already had they already had a chance to
do that with with the cont KI Brown
Jackson seat come to and ask her she she
right my point is there may be a back
room deal with kamla Harris but how do
you publicly explain KLA Harris no
longer being in the running for
president KLA Harris wants the job she
wants the job she ran for the job and
you don't think there's anything they
could offer her as a substitute like
what what's what's a sub to be president
the first black woman president there is
there's nothing that's the thing I mean
there was this idea that theoretically
they could offer her a supreme court
care but I don't think she they could
offer her Treasure of black lives matter
love there's a lot of money there Larry
I I'm running for that I appreciate I I
love the fact that you are here
delivering this information because this
all sounds this is all the greatest news
heard all day long regarding gav let me
think about Gavin aside from what I said
about KLA Harris what is Gavin Newsome
going to offer if you feel that we're on
the wrong track nothing he praised uh
the pull out of Afghanistan he's
probably the only major politician who
did he's a more extremist on climate
change than Joe Biden he wants to Outlaw
the sale of new gas powered cars as I
explained in my book as goes California
by the year 2035 he's more of a climate
change extremist than Biden is he loves
all the spending he set up a panel for
crying out loud for reparations in
California he's more left-wing than Joe
Biden if you're unhappy with how the
country is going what makes you think
Gavin Nome has prescription to make
things better so you know I know like
you're really you know philosophy and
stuff and you know about Mark Hughes and
stuff like that is Gavin Nome
is he a True Believer or is he just
someone that is doing what he's told by
like people that know Theory and people
that know it's not that complicated
Gavin Newsome is just dumb he's just
dumb okay I mean I mean raising taxes
people leaving California and you want
to raise even more taxes okay he's just
dumb so it has nothing to do with any
philosophy left is philosophy I don't
think so well you'd know better than I
he shut down the state in a more severe
way than anybody else did while leaving
his own private Winery open his own kids
in private school it tick people off
which is he faced a recall election he
doesn't he doesn't get it I was
surprised that he he survived that
recall to be honest with you and by the
way his numbers now are the worst
they've ever been and they're citing
crime and homelessness at the two
reasons why and they and they cheated
you out of that yeah do you want to
break down for us how that went down
with you know you were running it looked
like you were a couple things happened
Tim first of all as I explained in my
book they tried to keep me off the
ballot the first provisional ballot
comes out Elders name's not on it even
though we did all the things both to get
signatures and this that and the other
do all the filing and you have to turn
in five years of your tax returns by the
way I think illegally uh was a there was
a law that was passed by the California
legislature this is before Donald
Trump's tax returns had been
illegally exposed because they wanted
him to turn them over even the outgoing
Governor Jerry Brown didn't sign it
because he thought it was a violation of
the 14th Amendment of the of the
Constitution so Gavin new comes in signs
it and requires anybody running for
president or Governor to turn over 5
years of tax returns we didn't even feel
it appli to a recall election but we did
it anyway you have to do five sets 500
pages and 500 pages for reasons that
still I don't understand there were
seven pages missing from the second set
of of of the two so the California
secretary of state says Elder is not
eligible because he did not comply with
the requirements wow even though there's
a provision that says if there's a Minor
error the secretary of state has the
power to correct that Minor error so we
Fil A lawsuit and the judge who heard
the lawsuit was a Berkeley Cal you see
Berkeley graduate not good female not
good Democrat not good and up for a
judgeship by Gavin Newsome not good not
good not good not good wow it's on
YouTube the hearing it was about 15
minutes long and she said to the uh the
California lawyers gentlemen first of
all the California secretary of state
has a power to correct A Minor error and
all you had to do is look at the first
set to find the seven pages that were
missing from the second set you didn't
even do that and secondly I don't even
believe the law applies to a recall
election what do you have to say and it
was over it was done wow really so
that's the first thing they did and then
of course she signed in for your for you
right away right away slam boah I told
my lawyer that my cousin Vinnie could wi
this win this case and he said all right
hire my cousin Vinnie I said come back
come back I was joking I was joking uh
but the big thing is that in California
we have we have this endless voting
almost six weeks and during the campaign
I made a in my opinion one tactical
mistake I made was I never told uh said
anything at my rallies to go and vote
right now but I knew our people were
going to show up and vote on the same
day which they did long lines almost as
long as the election of of of 2020 but
they had been collecting ballots for
almost five or six weeks and there
ballot harvesting I didn't tell people
to do that yeah and uh we need to get in
that game and in California registered
Republicans are outnumbered by
non-registered Republicans 3 to1 I got
out spent 10 to1 uh Inc comes uh and for
a while was a two-step deal the first
part is do you want Gavin news recalled
and the 50% plus one said yes whoever
got the most votes on their on the
replacement side would win there were 46
candidates including myself on the
replacement side I got
3.5 million votes more than almost all
the others combined California has 58
counties on the replacement side I carry
57 to 58 the only one I lost was San
Francisco and I lost that by weit for it
149 votes I raised $27 million in 7
weeks um Gavin Nome outspent me 10 to1
and for a while the first part of the
ballot do you want Gavin Nome recall was
in the margin of error they were scared
bleess big article in The Hollywood
Reporter Gavin new called out all these
entertainers to come in a Snoop Dog uh
uh tweeted against me whole bunch of
other celebrities tweeted against me in
comes Joe Biden he says Larry Elder is
the closest thing to a Donald Trump
clone has I've ever seen I don't know if
I should the closest thing to a Donald
Trump I don't know if I should have been
flattered or or offended
but uh uh Barack Obama cut a commercial
for him uh KLA Harris did that that's
kind Warren did they all did and I took
one picture of Donald Trump in my life
at that time both of us had our thumbs
up together I saw that picture over and
over and over again they kept showing it
over and over again and they said this
they didn't say Gavin Newsome is doing a
great great job for the people of
California on crime on homelessness on
how bad our schools are on Water
Management on fire management the fact
of people are leaving no Gavin Nome stop
Republican takeover that's they said
over and over again that was the line
stop the Republican takeover no matter
how bad things are Republicans will make
things worse Democrats haven't run on
any of their uh achievements or anything
in in almost a decade now you know and
Phil opening I open my book with this
story about what happened after I ran
for for governor I go to a restaurant
west side of la la is liberal West
side's even more liberal I get there
about 15 minutes for my buddy and the
table over here with two ladies and I
think they feel sorry for me sitting
there by myself so we start talking
turns out they're 85 years old uh
they've known each other since the
second grade one of them was celebrating
her 85th birthday one of them said she's
a human rights proponent whatever that
is and then about 15 20 minutes into the
conversation she say wait a minute I
Know Who You Are you're that guy that
ran in the recall that you're that Larry
Elder she smiled she said guess who we
voted for I said you didn't vote for me
I said how do you know that I said let's
see we're on the west side of La you're
both Jewish one of you was a human
rights activist you didn't vote for me
and they admitted they had they had not
I said let me ask you something how do
you feel about the crime and they both
admitted they knew people who got mugged
how do you feel about the um way grain
news shut down the state they both said
that they loost they knew people who
lost their businesses a third of all
restaurants gone forever in California
how do you feel about schools they both
admitted they would never put their kid
in in a public school in Los Angeles to
save their lives how do you feel about
the fact that people are leaving they
both admitted they lost
friends I said so here we are completing
each other's sentences but you didn't
vote for me have you ever had a
conversation with a Conservative
Republican before they look at each
other and they said we have not yeah I
also talk in my book about I've got some
back issues I know you're a skateboarder
I could never do that I've got some back
issues and a friend of mine recommended
this massage therapist who said you
could do some he said could do some
interesting things with my back so I go
to this place I think it's going to be
an office building I drive down a
residential street I knock on this house
door opens up lady come to the door
she's got tattoos everywhere piercings
everywhere but her eyeballs her hair is
four or five different colors I get hit
in the face with a big plume of of
marijuana smoke not that I would know
what that would smell like guys and she
started working you probably right I she
starts working on my back she's playing
Motown music which is my favorite genre
of music not rap Motown and there's a
song that comes on my girl probably my
favorite song of all time and I told her
this is written by Smoky Robins he wrote
it for a guy named David Ruffin who's in
the lead singer of The Temptations who
unfortunately had a drug overdose and
the song comes on oh this is Marvin Gay
from from a song called what's Happening
Now Barry Gord the CEO of uh mtown
didn't want him to record it because bar
liked to control all the rights of
recording wow and they did it anyway and
became the biggest hit mtown ever had
every song that came on I knew the
backstory and she said about a half hour
I know who you are when you called to
make the appointment I knew who you were
I didn't want to say anything because um
you know didn't vote for you had I known
you were this personable and it's funny
I would have voted for you and and I
said I said do you know any Republicans
and she said no I said not one she said
no I said let me News Bulletin we have
personalities we have Sensi of humor she
didn't know a single Republican remember
remember when Bob Dole was running and
how stiff he was and then after he got
done after the election he went on I
think it was SNL and everybody was like
if I saw that Bob Dole or a bunch of
people were like if I saw that Bob Dole
I would have voted for him because he
was personable and the way that they
wanted him to be on the campaign Trail
was really stiff and and and formal
that's what Obama had right yeah he was
great but Tim I am funny I am personable
I am likable and they know that that is
why they attacked me the way they did
I'm also humble that's why the other
times call me the black face of white
supremacy in fact it was not even bued
in the article it was a headline Larry
Elder is the black face of white
supremacy sub headline you've been
warned but you also don't get support
from the RNC I mean this year when you
were shut out of the debate they used to
crazy oh this poll doesn't count you're
affiliated with it and so is Donald
Trump I mean don't get me started on
that okay you got definitely definitely
because Ronald McDaniel's the worst
thing about the Republican party right
now and it was shortly after you were
here last time and there's a lot of
things that are bad about the Republican
party I had to submit three polls where
I said 1% or better done done and done
she calls me up when the deadline is
over and says I can't use you can't use
one of those polls I said which one Ras
M poll I said why because it's
affiliated with the Trump campaign and
it is true the rules were any poll
affiliated with any candidate cannot be
used by any other candidate and I said I
submitted a fourth one and she said well
you submitted it too late well because I
didn't realize they needed to submit for
and by the way mm promptly put out a
tweet and said Larry Elder can use us we
are not affiliated with the Trump
campaign and they still didn't put me up
I threatened to file a complaint with
the FEC for $100 million my lawyer is
the former chair of the FEC and he said
by failing to apply the debate criteria
failure uh fairly to you what the RNC
did essentially was was to give an
in-kind contribution to the eight people
who did make the debate stage and based
on the value of the two hours of the uh
Fox News time that's $100 million I said
if you don't put me on I went to
Milwaukee even though I I was told I
wasn't going to be on the stage I went
to Milwaukee and I told Ron McDaniel and
the and the RNC if you don't put me up
there make the announcement by 2 o'clock
I'm going to file this complaint and 2
o'cl came and went they didn't do it so
I filed the complaint so right now
they're facing $1 million doll complaint
I with the FC I hope you win and then
when all the 100 million or whatever
have left goes to you you have some kind
of weird pseudo alternate version of the
RNC which is substantially better than
whatever it is they're doing now either
that either that I go do you think that
there's a a way that do a lot of drugs
and marijana you'll buy all of the
original pressing Motown album there you
go yeah do you think there's a way the
RNC could write the ship I mean is it a
change in leadership that would change
these I think had har meet Dylan won
that election oh yeah everything would
have been different by the way they
didn't help me either during the recall
yeah that's what I remembered first and
then the presidential uh the Kevin
McCarthy at the time uh told all the
dozen or so House Representatives uh to
endorse a guy named Kevin fauler
two-term mayor of San Diego
and only two publicly endorsed me they
were Michelle Lee and Doug Lala from the
Sacramento area by the way I carried uh
San Diego County by 30 points wow and it
was obvious that the that the uh
Grassroots wanted me I mean when I
announced I had no idea what was going
to happen I immediately shot to the top
of the poles and every time they had a
debate and I didn't go to any of the
debates because I was raising money and
also we all knew what the issues were I
figured all that would happen is we chew
each other up and Gavin new would have a
lot of sound that he would use against
us which is why by the way I believe
that Nikki Haley should drop out of the
race uh she's making Donald Trump spend
money she's given Joe Biden a lot of
sound bites he can use against him she
made a comment today just just before we
started talking about the uh finding
against Trump which I understand you
want to attack your opponent but it's a
totally BS finding like it's absolutely
outside of the realm reality what good
does it do I mean and to use that it
legitimizes it from a person who took a
pledge to rep whichever Republican could
beat Joe Biden Donald Trump's not the
one who let in 8 million people Donald
Trump's not the one that made us go from
energy independent to having gas prices
almost twice what they were Donald Trump
is not the one that made inflation get
to 40 40-year High he's not the problem
he's not the problem and and it's and
it's also to me damaging her four years
down the road because assuming that that
Donald Trump is a nominee and assuming
for a moment that he loses and we do the
postmortem on your show Tim one of the
reasons you're going to offer is what uh
is that Nikki hilly stayed in too long
cost Donald Trump money that could have
been used against uh against Joe Biden
and gave Donald Trump a lot of tape that
he used against him in ads let me let me
jump to the story as we're talking about
this race we have this from cnr.com
Trump ordered to pay 83.3 million in
Damages to egene Caroll our legal system
is out of control and being used as a
political weapon the former president
said in response now Trump has
repeatedly said he never met this woman
many on social media have pointed out
that her story about Trump is the plot
to episode of Law and Order
SVU yeah did you not hear that yeah no
it was it was um similar to a plot that
was in a in in a Law and Order I'm not
saying she got it from there but off are
po out kinky dinky isn't it and then we
have this from Nikki Haley who tweets
yeah Donald Trump wants to be the
presumptive Republican nominee and we're
talking about $83 million in Damages
we're not talking about fixing the
Border we're not talking about tackling
inflation America can do better than
Donald Trump and Joe Biden let me tell
you what Nikki Haley is doing here first
Donald Trump issued a statement saying
he does not want to be the presumptive
Nomine he wants to win legitimately and
and these These primar are actually good
for him so she's lying there and then
she is taking an attack from Democrats
to use against the most popular
Republican right now this is
disqualifying she's a Democrat she's got
Democrat donors Democrat voters and
she's using Democrat tactics to try and
go after Donald Trump and using Larry
Elder's tagline for decades I've been
saying we got a country to save and I
said it over and over again during the
campaign all of a sudden Nikki Hill has
been saying it we she's been ending her
speeches with we've got a country to
Safe stole it from the great urki I get
no royalties I get nothing the great El
DKI I love it and if Donald Trump has to
pay her $83 million why I should have
sued the LA times for defamation when I
was called the blackface of right
Supremacy what could I have gotten well
this is what's laughable nothing because
we live in the logic of Herbert M this
is laughable I I actually tweeted
something at Frank Lun CU he was talking
about it I'm just like anybody who works
in media and journalism knows this is
fake and any journalist claiming
otherwise is lying to you why every
journalist knows times V Sullivan
because every day you write about
someone it has you work you work for LA
Times oh wait sorry you work for LA
Times anymore uh you work for the New
York Times when you're writing a story
it's got to get checked by legal legal
has to the lawyer goes through and make
sure you're not in violation they all
are aware of defamation and Lial laws
and so here Donald Trump is being told
to pay $83 million
he's not allowed to say he didn't do it
it's it's it's remarkable but Trump said
several times in court when this going
down this isn't this is not America and
the scary thing is we are now in the in
the world where there is no law there's
none there is only left and right jurry
pools and good luck and double standard
you've got um uh Navaro facing four
months for defying a subpoena meanwhile
Eric Holder was the first AG to be found
in criminal contempt of congress for
failing to to to a supply to comply with
a subpoena when he was required to turn
over documents regarding Fast and
Furious nothing happened to him no I
mean there's a complete double standard
even though I mean even in this case if
you read the excerpt from egene Carol's
book where she accuses Donald Trump she
says it was in maybe the summer or maybe
the fall but maybe the spring she can't
remember any of the details she says the
dress is still hung in her closet like
all of her allegations are ridiculous on
their face and he's never been tried in
a criminal court right he has just been
put through Civil Trial he's never he's
never been allowed to he's never in fact
he wasn't allowed to defend himself when
he was president just speaking openly
but she was allowed to make allegations
with no basis there was a boatload of
tweets that that the Trump uh defense
team wanted to submit that were
incredibly graphic and called into
question whether or not een Carroll is
the kind of person that would be
considered promiscuous or you know just
really reliable um and they just said no
we can't you can't put them into it's a
complete double standard she was allowed
to be treated in a way that Donald Trump
was not allowed to be treated the
problem and Larry knows this just as
well as anyone else and it's something
that I harp on we live in the logic of
Herbert maruse we live in a society
where one political opinion is
acceptable to attack it is acceptable to
uh to use the government against one
group of people that have a certain
political opinion it is acceptable to be
violent against them it's acceptable to
hit them it's acceptable to take their
property you don't think that that's the
case that may have been 10 years ago but
since the since the culture War expanded
to the point where we're at now with
like budlight I think it's now clear
that institutions have no problem
espousing the ideology of their side the
issue with this is that Donald Trump was
sued in New York City where it is a
stronghold of Communists jurisdiction
does matter yes fair enough Donald Trump
should sue in West Virginia where 86% of
West Virginia are huge Trump fans and
the jury pool would be like we are
impartial Trump should sue her for
defamation in West Virginia the question
is why does he not if Trump went to West
Virginia and said oh I got a house here
I I'm suing her here he'd win in two
seconds he'd win 83.3 million in fact
he'd win simply because I guarantee you
you you you you pull a 100 West Virginia
about this and they're going to be
pissed off not everybody's going to know
about it don't get me wrong but if they
know they're going to be like they're
doing what to Donald Trump in fact you
go to the W you go to Western Maryland
okay Maryland which is you know
Baltimore is basically got its boot on
it and we went to a we went to a diner
and they had flags of Donald Trump
riding a tank standing on a tank with
fireworks exploding and him holding like
an Uzi there's one of him on a
velociraptor and I'm like these people
love Donald Trump Donald sue her back
and do it here and sue her for defaming
you for claiming falsely how amazing
would it be you you could even do it in
the middle of California I talk about
this in my book I Trav up from down the
state there large portions of that state
where they love Donald Trump I'm driving
I see big Trump signs the farmers love
him people in the middle of the state
adore him it's people in the Bay Area in
San Diego and in La they're the problem
this is what we need right now we need
Donald Trump to sue egene Carroll in
West Virginia so that we get a default
verdict same as as however it is his
cases are going down where they say it
was false and defamatory that she
claimed Trump assaulted her and that she
has to because of it so then New York
says no Trump did and then West Virginia
says no she lied and then there you go
the the issue right now what you're
bringing up Phil is that it's true in
the sense that if you are that it's true
that Democrats and their institutions
have no problem breaking the rules and
doing these things the only issue is I
don't see Trump filing a lawsuit in W
like Trump could just choose to do it
he's not yeah I not doing it I I have no
no qual with what you're saying and and
I agree the solution to this stuff is
law fair you know it it is to do bring
as many lawsuits against any politician
any organization that's left leaning
anything that you can come up with but
do you think that meant he would have
had to sue egene Carroll in 2019 when
she first released this book I have no
idea because I mean theoretically that
would have been the first way to set
president who car else he would have
been the president and they would have
freaked out but it doesn't matter
because what we're clearly seeing here
is lawfare this the the trial against
Trump for fraud in New York is clearly
false
these claims are are ridiculous on their
face so if they're going to I mean look
they they created a new law where women
could bring up old cases and Sue over it
or something like this so that they
could uh uh which case was that was it
was it egene Carroll where she could
claim that because I think this is
defamation this was not related to
sexual assault or I'm not talking about
her lobbying to change the laws in there
was a law that said you had a we're
going to introduce a one-year window
where people can sue after Harvey
Weinstein right okay was that that was
for Weinstein I I if if they're going to
play this game and all that really
matters is a judge is going to determine
for some re reason or another Trump is
not allowed to defend himself so let's
look at the fraud case the judge ruled
uh in default he said Noe Trump trump
committed fraud end of story have a nice
day you can't defend yourself they just
bang the gavl it's done okay well Trump
go to West Virginia and find someone who
do the exact same thing in the other
other direction there there there we go
it's the only way it's going to change
or the only only moves we can make and
there a bunch of Republican AGS who also
could figure out all sorts of ways to
sue um democrats for this that and the
other that's another thing that's mading
is there's plenty of Republican AGS they
should be they should be inundating
Democrat politicians for anything it
should be it should be No Holds Barred
law fair just as much as much litigation
as possible this is the way they want it
give it to them you know there's so many
double standards one of them is this
election Den stuff Hillary for four
years referred to Donald Trump is
illegitimate said the election was
stolen uh the did you see just the other
day when Biden said that the governor of
Virginia no governor of uh yeah Virginia
was was a real Governor yeah and you had
the uh the race in georia um Stacy uh
what's your last Abrams yeah Stacy
Abrams claims that uh uh she lost
because of voter fraud uh Hillary for
four years referred to Donald Trump as
illegitimate four years and the AG DHS
secretary under Obama J Johnson
testified under oath not a single vote
tally was changed by the Russians they
tried but they failed to change a single
vot 66% of Democrats according to a ug
poll believe the Russians change vote
Tes to get Donald Trump elected Jimmy
Carter said it yeah yeah imagine the
president saying that election was
stolen it is it is in it is
Indescribable to to to try and explain
to people like what it's like trying to
to make people understand that that the
idea that like the conservatives are
living in a fantasy world and you hear
the the rhetoric coming out of the out
of like MSNBC and and CBS and all the
the the you know the the standard
narrative producing uh organizations
smar Merchants whenever whenever I said
people push back and go well Hillary
didn't file a lawsuit yes she did she
joined the lawsuit that Jill Stein filed
against uh Wisconsin and filed a
separate motion to have the recall
recount done by hand well Hillary didn't
didn't storm the capital people on
January 6th because she wasn't president
but Donald Trump got elected in November
there were 40 cities where there were
protests including violent protests
police cars set on fire in DC hundreds
were arrested and get this not only were
there hundreds of people setting fires
smashing things that that was at the at
the inauguration at the inauguration the
city actually paid the the riers yeah
the city paid the riers out yeah there
were two or three hundred of them as I
recall but I'm talking about when Donald
Trump got elected there were 40 cities
where there were violent protests all
over including setting fire to police
station my point is had Hillary been
president and the she were on the other
foot in the election was this
questionable you're telling me that her
supporters would said oh well let's rub
some donut we'll get back Obama engaged
in
Insurrection Barack Obama waged
Insurrection in what way well he was
president when all of his supporters
went out and started burning things down
so that clearly means Barack Obama from
rhetor because I don't I don't recall
Donald Trump saying to be violent or
stormed anything in fact I recall Trump
saying go and he said he said I want you
to peacefully and patriotically make
your voices
heard said that that the people that
were out in the streets should be spec
she that verbatim and they should be
they're not going to she was saying
they're not going to stop they're not
going to stop they're out there and they
should be but why do you think people
forget these things like all of these
details get the the BM riots I I don't
think they forget I think the issue is
Democrats don't know and don't care uh
I'm going to use Marian Williamson as a
good example I heard she just dropped
out recently too uh I don't know if
that's true did she I think I think she
may have you want to check but um Mar
Williamson is a is is a lovely woman
she's very nice she's very smart but
she's unfortunately living in Wawa world
where she wants a department of Peace
doesn't she well yeah when when when
when we had her here and we said here is
a bad thing that is happening she goes
oh my that is so bad I say here's
another bad thing we're concerned about
goes wow I didn't know that was
happening wow when you show her hey
here's news like for example there's a
book called not my idea which is being
given to children in public schools
where it depicts white people a white
person as a devil offering you a
whiteness contract she nearly cried when
she saw it the issue with Marin
Williamson and many default liberals is
they are they are being manipulated by
demonic I mean that figuratively some
might mean it literally propagandists
and they're not aware of what's going on
now you said why don't do people forget
or not remember all of us remember all
of it she's still in she's still in oh
okay I apologize uh all of us remember
all of this stuff and we talk about it
all the time and we'll be on the show
and say remember when this happened
remember what that happened it's that
people like Maryann and her followers
are never exposed to it in the first
place regarding the George Floyd BLM
riots starting in May of 2020 4 months
long they're in the streets because of
an assumption that would happened to uh
George Floyd had to do with his race the
lead prosecutor was a black man opening
statement I'm a lawyer the most
important part of a triy opening
statement in his opening statement he
took pains to say police in general are
not on trial the Minneapolis PD in
general is not on trial this individual
is on trial in fact he said police are
are doing a good job they have to make
split decisions life and death in a in a
very short period of time this
individual is on trial for what he did
what he didn't do and he was never even
charged with a hate crime yet most
people out in the streets because of the
assumption that what happened to George
Floyd had to do with his race there's a
website called polic mag.com my last
point and uh people who are
self-described as very liberal were
asked how many unarmed black men did the
police kill in
2019 one 50% of the self-described very
liberal people thought the police killed
1,000 unarmed black men in 2019 8%
thought they killed 10,000 wow what what
did the regular self-described liberal
people think 39% of them thought the
police killed 1,000 unarmed black men in
2019 5% thought they killed 10,000 the
answer according to the Washington Post
database was 12 yeah that's the gap
between what they think is going on and
the reality no wonder you're out in the
street I'd be out on the street if I
thought the police killed 10,000 black
men on our black men every day I think
Ben said the same thing he was like man
I I think Ben was like I would be
protesting with you if I thought the
police were doing this clueless and
again the point is that the lead
prosecutor of black man never even
implied that what what uh Derek schin
did had anything to do with George
Floyd's race there's a man on the street
video where someone uses that data and
asks you know young black students at a
college how many you know black men are
shot every year and they're shocked when
they find the number is 12 but there's
one guy in particular who argues with
him he's like really only 12 why don't
we say why don't we say like a 100 he's
like no we can't say a 100 the number 12
round it up to 100 and it's like this
thing where the guy just cannot accept
and so he asked to compromise on the
number but the number by the way unarmed
does not mean not dangerous yeah uh
Michael Brown was unarmed but he had
just done a strong armed robbery his DNA
was found on the officer's gun uh so
does not mean you're perceive as
dangerous remember if few years ago that
guy named amadu dialo uh immigrant was
cornered because he fit the description
police said show your hands show your
hands he goes and reaches into his to
his wallet and they thought it was
reason for a gun they blew him away
Hillary called these four officers
murderers a a multi-ethnic jury found
all four officers not guilty because the
gesture was reasonably perceived as
threatening so just because you're not
on arm doesn't mean you're not dangerous
so even the number 12 is probably even
smaller than that when you people we had
we have had conservatives come on this
show and I have talked about the almed
Arbury case and they did not know the
details of this case they still thought
it was a guy jogging right you had when
the McMichaels were convicted and I
forgot the other guy's name I should
probably learn his name to be honest uh
the guy who simply filmed it also went
to prison you had high-profile prominent
conservatives say something to the
effect of this proves conservatives
aren't racist as if to imply this time
the Amed with Amed Arbury it actually
was a racist attack when in reality the
issue at hand found in the court was not
whether or not there was a hate crime
committed it was whether or
not while we all agree ammed Arbury was
in the was in the act of committing a
felony the question is did the
McMichaels have a right to stop himh and
the jury found that McMichaels did not
have a right to stop the man who we
believe was committing the felony
because they did not witness the felony
themselves so any subsequent action was
their responsibility Ahmed Arbury
confronting them trying to grab the
shotgun from I believe it's Travis
McMichael the shotgun goes off SE a
couple times in the fight aled Arbury
takes it to the chest and dies they are
criminally responsible because they
should not have and and and fair point
they were told not to however I've had
conservatives come on the show and say
oh wasn't those a white guys chased on a
black guy who was drugging and I'm like
my friend the joing story got told over
and over it the headline he was he was
might have been jogging like all the
time it's uh William Bryan is the man
who video will despite the fact that
police had evidence of him burglarizing
home that the police had gone door to
door and say this is the guy we believe
is burglarizing the home right and that
a gun had been stolen so when someone
said hey it's that guy again McMichael's
gotten their car and chased after him
called the police the police said do not
follow they should not have followed but
many people argu the morality of if your
neighborhood is being you know
effectively terrorized by this repeat
burglar and even someone who even stole
a gun you're you're going to want to
stop that there's a moral issue there so
the question ultimately became and the
jury decided wrong um the the the law
states that if a misdemeanor is
committed and you witness it you have a
right to citizens arrest however if a
felony is committed and uh you do not
need to be a witness simply someone
could say that person committed a felony
stopped them uh however because of the
way the law was written in a very
archaic fashion the judge said to the
jury you decide whether or not they
needed to be Witnesses or not and the
jury said they should have been
Witnesses therefore they've Comm they're
criminally responsible for the death Tim
but the big thing is this became a
national story a national narrative uh
Lebron James tweets that black people
are afraid to leave their homes when in
fact it is rare for a white person to
kill a black person anytime it is rare
there about 20,000 homicides every year
most homicide is same race homicide most
blacks who are murdered or murdered by
other blacks most whites who are
murdered or murdered by other other
whites however year there roughly 750
interracial black white homicides 500
white people killed by blacks even
though blacks are just 13% of the
population 250 whites killed by blacks
even though black 250 blacks killed by
whites even though whites are 60% of the
population it is very very rare for it
to happen that that's homicide let's
talk about violent crime between blacks
and whites roughly 600,000 such
instances every year by then I'm talking
about attempted murder manslaughter rape
assault with a with a weapon aggravated
assault 600,000 000 every single year 85
to 90% is a black per white victim only
10% the other way around so if anybody
has a has a has a grievance it ought to
be white
people because the because the numbers
overwhelmingly show that they are more
likely to be to be victims of crime by
black people but here's here's the real
grievance it is white people who hate
white people so why feel guilty or well
knows it's we would describe it as
outgroup preference this is the the the
survey that went viral several years ago
white Liberals are the only demographic
with a with a racial outgroup preference
so uh uh it's it so black people have a
slight bias towards black people Latinos
towards Latinos Asians towards Asians
white conservatives towards white people
liberals against white people so I don't
I don't think the issue actually is that
uh they have a grievance about
whiteonblack crime I think that white
liberals generally just don't like white
people and so if anything interrupts
their narrative about white people
that's when they go on the offensive so
for example Asians don't fit the The
Narrative of white privilege so Asians
don't get included in their in their
benefits package of how we got to help
minorities right so it's really just
white people are bad have a nice day
well I I phrased it somewhat differently
I I said whoever said compound interest
is the greatest force in the universe
and by the way I check it wasn't
Einstein who said it whoever said
compound interest is the greatest force
in the universe never encountered white
guilt I just think there's a whole bunch
of white people that feel really really
bad about slavery really really bad
about Jim Crow really really bad about
black people used to be treated and this
is their way of making up I I I I hear
you and I can understand that but I kind
of think they're just white supremacists
and I mean that in the literal sense we
saw that Yale study we love to cite
where white liberals speak down to black
people and white conservatives don't
white conservatives meet a black guy
they talk to him like normal white
liberals they they dumb themselves what
up they they but but not even that they
they like they use second grade
vocabulary like the these people in my
mind I don't think they have white guilt
I think they have a white superiority
complex where they imagine them going
like well we're so much better than they
are they need our help that's but I'll
give you a quick example it's White
Man's Burden right so I met uh uh these
activists when I was in North Dakota at
the no Dakota access pipeline protest
and I'm there to document stuff but of
course it's all leftist protesters who
are very you know woke and I'm sitting
down for dinner cuz I I friends of
friends and we get into a conversation
this one guy brings up you uh so what
happens is I said I got to leave
tomorrow because I have I have to drive
to California I have a meeting in the at
9:00 in the morning in 3 days so I got
to drive overnight and he said and he
smirks and
says a meeting at 9:00 a.m. he's like
that's Colonial thinking and I asked him
what is colonial thinking what I have a
meaning and he's like it's Colonial
thinking dude like having a schedule to
wake up you think the Native Americans
do that they wake up when they need to
wake up they wake up when the sun comes
up and I was like n white people didn't
invent time or scheduling dude and he
was like yeah they did it was the
colonists who brought all that stuff and
I was like bro people in Asia have time
and can track the hours of the day and
decide we should meet at a certain point
of the day and he goes no it's it was
white people who brought that and I was
like my dude the Chinese invented
compasses 1,000 years before you did and
he goes no it's it's white Europeans who
brought all that stuff to China and I'm
like holy crap this guy literally thinks
white Europeans invented everything
developed science technology and then
exported that to Asia and I'm like is
this true China invented compasses a
thousand years before Europeans did I
don't hold that against or in I don't
say wow Asia you're so great or Europe
you're so dumb it's just a thing that
happened but these people believe white
people invented everything they're just
white supremacist they invented it to
oppress other people that's the other
part to benefit themselves and to make
it harder for everyone else to exist
they made the compass to control
Direction so that yeah they invented
racism they gravity to keep us all down
I mean white people are out of control
that's a joke but like when it comes to
like RAC they they have part of the
theory is white people created racism in
order to oppress other races have you
seen video that Amy Horwitz did
regarding voter ID oh it's a class oh my
they ask all these college students um
uh you know why is it that black people
can't get voter ID well they just they
don't don't have access to the internet
so he goes to go them he says do you he
asks them do you think a black person
would not be able to get an ID or
whatever and they all say yeah they said
no yeah they couldn't they they don't
have access to the to computers un they
can't find the DMV so they go to they go
to Harlem do you have a ID yeah I got an
ID you know
the you know do you know anybody who has
I don't know anybody who doesn't have ID
my favorite my favorite I have to bring
up my favorite my favorite is they one
of the one of the excuses the Berkeley
kids give is they they have trouble
finding the DMV right and so he meets
this like older black guy and he's like
can I ask you a question he's like yeah
and he's like do you know the DMV is and
he goes oh yeah just go up here on 25th
he's giving him directions because a
normal question that's the thing it's
like it's like and one woman was was was
was told that a lot of people don't
think you can get ID and she said who
thinks that and he said you think it's
racist she said yeah kind of there's
there's this thing that goes on in in
like the the critical social justice
movement and stuff is they they want to
think about their Blackness first and
it's like they forget that they're
people it's like these are normal people
things to do finding out where in the
city a building is is not some massive
challenge the idea that a a whole entire
race can't find an address look look
look it's so offensive I think think
about what these Berkeley kids must
think of the average intellect of a
black person who can't figure out what a
building is a few blocks away I mean
that is a it's a white supremacist idea
people could not find a building I'm on
the campaign I announc before Tim Scott
did Tim Scott announces I get a phone
call from a
reporter you and Tim Scott are both
black Republicans what distinguishes you
from Tim Scott I said I said in 2016
When Donald Trump announced it you say
you are both white Republicans what
distinguishes you from Jeb Bush and she
was quiet for 15 seconds she said Point
made but she's not sorry she asked she
said Point made but she's going to ask
it again she she was through the
question so I didn't I mean from Tim
Scott I would have trolled her
relentlessly like I would have just
started I said I'm better looking no I
mean I would just started I would just
say a bunch of like self-deprecating
racist things like is is that what you
wanted to hear it's ridiculous no it's
crazy but I do think that they
ultimately race as as at the Forefront
of a progressive mind always and they
are always because they are all I think
whether it's they hate themselves
because they're they're it's whatever it
is they ultimately use that to say well
everything I've heard that is a
stereotype about another race that could
potentially be perceived negatively I
have to make sure I'm on guard against
it at all times which is way worse
what's your describing is the result of
people being taught critical race Theory
critical race theory in of itself is not
ideas critical race theory is a way to
approach the world it is seeing race
before anything else so when we were
arguing oh we don't want to teach kids
critical race Theory we weren't arguing
oh you don't want kids to know history
or know that there are different types
of people different color people in
America whatever it is we don't want
people to have the illiberal view that
race comes before the human being I got
I got to read this super chat from uh
Jason Hutchinson CU he makes a really
good point black people work at the
DMV but they get lost all the time dude
these these these these Berkeley College
kids are like that racist if you're
black and you get hired at DMV you have
to ask ask for
I make this point in my book I was in
Boston in 2004 when this guy with funny
ears skinny guy whose name nobody could
pronounce came out and gave the intro
speech for John krey and Barack Obama
said there's no blue America there's no
red America people went nuts there's no
Black America there's no White America
people went nuts he decided to run for
president he's on 60 Minutes he was not
yet the front runner but he's catching
Hillary and the correspondent said
Senator if you don't win will it be
because of race and I sat back and I
said let's see what this guy says he's
going to give some sort of victorr
answer the way Al sharpen did when he
ran and lost and claim was racism or
Jesse Jackson ran twice and lost and
said it was racism Senator Obama said no
if I don't win it will be because I have
not articulated a view that the American
people can can Embrace he also gave a
speech at a black church when he was
running he talked about how much racism
he thought was still in America and he
said the Moses generation referring to
the generation of Martin Luther King the
Moses generation has gotten us 90% of
the way there my generation the Joshua
generation has to get us at additional
10% which I thought Phil was reasonable
because there was a fox opinion poll 200
2 8% of Americans believe Elvis is still
alive 6% believe if you send him a
letter he'll get it so 8% 8% you got to
wipe out so basically what he was saying
we have 2% to work on he gets elected
both polls show that blacks and whites
thought race relations would improved
when he left both blacks and whites
thought they got worse why for eight
years this dude played the race car Time
and Time and Time Again from the C
police cambri police acted stupidly
Trayvon Martin he invoked black lives
matter he talked about Ferguson at at a
UN speech gave an interview to a podcast
and said racism is in America's DNA so
this this is What communists do and then
and then he brought in Al sharpen over
70 times what happened to the guy that I
saw in Boston yeah that's What
communists do do you think was he lying
they're intention was he lying at the
time if Barack Obama is is is actually a
Marxist or does not have a liberal
worldview then he it's completely within
reason to think that he was lying
because those ideologies are
intentionally subversive they
he has to have been lying because what
he said is just the opposite of what he
ran on the guy that America thought they
hired even people didn't vote for him
were crying because they said okay we've
reached a threshold here in 1964 MLK
gives a speech before British television
and he said I'm I'm amazed this is right
after the passage of the Civil Rights
Act of 64 he said I'm amazed that the
progress America has made in the last
couple years why in 40 years time we
could have a black president almost on
QE brck Obama he didn't say in 40 years
time there'll be black CEOs The Fortune
500 companies and there have been he
didn't say in 40 years time there'll be
black presidents of IV league
universities and there are he didn't say
the three biggest cities would all have
black Mayors La New York Chicago and
they do he said president meaning once
it happens it's done it's done and now
people act like it never even happened
this the only majority white country
that's ever elected let alone reelected
a black president only majority white
countries had a secretary of state is
black we had back-to-back black
secretaries of state Secretary of
Defense is black I mean knock it
off the two most prestigious professions
in America are are powerful anyway are
doctors and lawyers the AMA is biggest
trade Association of of of of doctors
we've had two black presidents of the
AMA there's been a black president of
the ABA what more do you need to stay in
order to prove that for the most part if
you if you go to school invest in
yourself avoid the criminal justice
system don't make bad moral mistakes
you'll be fine in America no matter what
race you are what more needs to be needs
to happen in order for us to to to say
that I think saying rational people who
pay attention to what's going on in the
world understand and the people who live
in the MSNBC CNN are staring at the
screen while drooling I think you're
right but the problem is those people
are so numerous and or they're numerous
enough that when combined with the
malicious they probably make a majority
of Americans between dumb and actually
malicious looking to use these things
for power that's probably enough think
about MSNBC this is a network that gave
a show to Al Sharpton he has a show
every weekend this is a guy who became
famous by falsely accusing a white man
of raping toan broley they have him on
tape agreeing to sell cocaine uh he did
the Freddy's fashion Mar Mart thing he
was in the in the head in the in the
middle of the 1991 Crown Heist riots
that one Jewish leader called the most
serious program in the history of
America he's made disparaging
disparaging remarks about Jew about Jews
about gays and he has a show every week
on MSNBC and is perceived to be a
Democrat kingmaker all these Democrats
who ran for president went to Harlem and
kissed his ring it's amazing stunning
can you imagine David Duke having a show
on Fox what we would say yeah it would
never happen right of course it would
never happen it should never happen and
Sharpton shouldn't have a show either
Sharpton should definitely not have a
show I me and he is extremely divisive
and encourages uh racial tensions
wherever he goes I mean that's how he
makes his money right he Street to
Ferguson before one moment of testimony
had been taken uh and the officer was
found completely exonerated that that
shot and killed uh uh Michael Brown and
there he's in the streets no justice no
peace no justice are you kidding me you
kidding me they still say it he
delivered the eulogy at Jordan Neely the
performer in New York who was in the
choke cold he immediately was like well
I'll deliver the eulogy because this was
definitely a racial thing never mind the
fact that the guy had an R R Us record
and was people called in saying he's
threatening people on the subway here's
you know what I think I think New York
wants to terrify people into fleeing
because the only people willing to stay
in a city that's going through what it's
going through are people who are going
to vote Democrat and so you bring in a
bunch of illegal immigrants you increase
your your your Congressional uh uh uh
seats and then you guarantee half the
people you brought in well or half the
people in your District can't vote
because they're not citizens now all you
need is 20,000 votes from these people
no conservative opposition
whatsoever you look at what what's going
on with the uh you know uh was it Daniel
penny in New York right because there's
Perry as well in Texas righten is the
one who held Jord exactly and people are
like I'm out I don't want to live here
anymore and they're like good ridd
because you were at risk of voting
Republican yeah I wanted you to go
that's interesting yeah my my my uh or
well one of the guys that I'm in
business with on the music side like
he's looking to get his family out of
there he's a Jewish guy he lives on Long
Island and he's got you know his kids go
to a Jewish school and he's like we are
looking to get the hell out of here and
you know he's a cons a fairly
conservative guy you know and he's just
like I don't feel safe here and it's not
worth taking a risk when you have a
family right I mean I think you've
talked about this a little bit the the
effect that fathers have on the family I
think the having a family really changes
the way people view the world and that's
one of the reasons Chang that we have we
have a society that or a government at
least that wants you to work not have
children defer having children don't get
married we take away people's ability to
look at one another and say hey I have
to do what I need to do to protect you
and to invest in your future which is
why black lives matter is so offensive
on their website they attack the nuclear
family yeah on their website you know
Barack Obama wrote a book which was very
good the first book dreams from my
father and it's all about The Angst he
felt because he didn't have his
biological father in his life last time
he saw his biological father he was 10
years old wow Al Sharpton Al Sharpton
had a nice middle class last life until
his father ran away and U with another
woman and then down to the hood he went
Jesse Jackson was raised by a single mom
uh who was impregnated by the married
man who lived next door and in South
Carolina where Jesse Jackson was raised
he was taunted by kids saying Jesse
ain't got no Daddy Jesse ain't got no
Daddy Al Sharpton's uh mother was
estranged from her father took had a
boyfriend took back up with the father
briefly got pregnant with Al Sharpton
and tried to abort him with a with a
coat hanger my point is these are
probably four of the most prominent
so-called black leaders in America all
of whom either had no relationship with
their own father or a bad one yet they
don't talk about it they don't talk
about it but they talk about systemic
racism and and it's never been less of a
problem in America racism than today and
they just demonize men for being men
that's one of the things that's I would
I would say you are correct 15 years ago
but with the rise of the woke left it's
racism is becoming a big problem yeah
but it's not the way they're describing
it the perception of racism become a big
no no no the left has created segregated
uh schooling programs in Sacramento they
had a white racial affinity group for
students they they've been doing these D
they do p p only and nonp rooms Dearborn
Michigan did this all the white people
in one room so it is becoming a problem
because of what the left is doing agreed
yeah and and if you are train again if
you are trained or if you are if you are
educated in a way where the first thing
that in every subject the first thing
that's brought up is race somehow
whether you're talking about geography
or whether you're talking about math or
whether you're talking about history
whatever e if somehow all of the topics
are tinged with racial discussion you're
going to be racist like that that you
are going to create racist people
because there is going to be a certain
percentage of the white people that hear
oh all white people are bad that are
going to resent it and that are going to
push back and say well screw you I'm
going to create a white affinity group
and you'll end up with more people that
are white supremacists more Nazis you'll
end up with uh blacks and minorities
that hate hate white people cuz they're
told hey all the white people all your
problems these things these are problems
that we are creating for our society we
are making these problems ourself we
don't have to do this and we're and
we're not being honest about it rasmon
is the only one that does this they ask
he has blacks Hispanics Asians and
whites of the four groups which one is
the most
racist Whit said blacks Asians said
blacks Hispanics said blacks blacks said
blacks wow blacks are two and a half
times more like the non-black Gentiles
to be anti-semitic we have a real
problem in the black community with
anti-Semitism and and and anti-white
bigotry nobody talks about it I want to
I want to your thoughts on something
because I've told the story on the show
before it's from occupi Wall Street and
uh there was we were all sitting around
in the middle of the park across the
street from occupy was I think it was a
Burger King that people would use the
bathroom in and uh there was this uh
this black dude that we all friends with
said I'm going to I'll be right back
guys I'm going to run to Burger King and
uh hit the bathroom this white guy goes
hey when you're over there can you grab
me a double cheeseburger and he goes
what and he just walks off and everyone
was like huh he comes back and he's like
do you see what happened man we were
talking and I was like what happened he
was like telling me to asking me to get
a cheeseburger for him and I was like
what do you mean he's like like I'm his
boy like I'm going to get his food for
him and I was like I think he's your
friend and he just wanted to see if
you'd grab him a cheeseburger when
you're over there like no you don't
understand dude you don't understand
what it's like and and what racism and
how it works and he perceived that
request yeah as racist yeah well maybe
your friend was hungry
how racist of him but that's that that's
what I felt I was kind of like I mean
when when I've been asked several times
during IAI to like if I'm going over
there grab a cheeseburger I've never
assumed it was because of my race or my
gender or anything about me I was just
like my friend wanted a cheeseburger
it's a normal response if someone says
that to to be like you know what I
really kind of don't want to know either
and like be like I feel uncomfortable
here and I want to not be in this
situation so I don't want to be around
to listen to you explain to me what it's
like to be asked to get a cheeseburger
you know it makes it makes for an
uncomfortable situation pushes people
farther apart because they can't talk
about like hey why did this upset you
instead it's like I've clearly done
something wrong so we're not going to
talk about it the other person doesn't
get to hear oh I just meant it like I
would have done the same for you you
were just going to run an erir and yeah
it it is you're my friend I just wanted
to see if you were going over there
you'd gra like I pay it back I don't
know right it's ultimately yeah it's low
trust and it it inhibits communication I
think that that's what all of this is
about making it so that no one can
actually say well I feel this way about
something this is how I perceive this
and feel like it is not someone trying
to have a power grab and have uh
influence over their life trying to
oppress them in some way I have a friend
that I grew up with about six blocks
from my house I grew up in in in South
Central uh both of us are black of
course and he was the most gifted
athlete that I've ever seen he was a
quarterback for the high school team he
was the starting uh two guard on the
basketball team he was the best pitcher
on the baseball team he picked up a
tennis racket never took a lesson hit it
against a back wall for two weeks and
then tried out and made a tennis team uh
he had a bad attitud to though he would
come late uh to practice but he still
started got started because the coach
wanted to win so fast forward I go away
to college I go away to law school I
come back to visit him he changed his
name to a Muslim name all of a sudden
the white man is oppressing him and I
said dude you and I went to the same
schools had the same teachers took the
same classes how come the white man
didn't stop me oh man you've been
indoctrinated and he changed his name to
a Muslim name and I told him that uh
Muslim slave trade was probably more
vicious and more nasty than the European
slave trade the rate of death for the
black slaves was higher he said oh you
reading white historians I said Henry
Lewis skip Gates is a is a white
historian he's a head of the black
studies department at
Harvard this is how vicious this kind of
stuff
is his mind was totally corrupted we
started yelling at each other screaming
at each other I told him he was a victim
and I said go go look in the effing
mirror your problem is you and until you
man up you're always going to live like
this not only does that steal happiness
now it steals your your motivation to
make your life in the future better
right like not you're you're angry
you're upset you feel like it's someone
else's fault so that makes you feel like
you can't do anything about it you're
told you can't do anything about it
there it's it's a it's I mean it's to
what you
saidul It ultimately says to him like
you are dependent on the world around
you there is no way for you to come up
so you might as well submit to it and
sort of cry out and protest as feebly as
you can and I think that must be a
completely horrifying experience to go
through on the other hand it is his
mentality to change nothing can save him
from himself I got I got to tell you the
the great life lesson that poker brings
you know what that lesson is it doesn't
matter what cards you're dealt it
matters how you play them uh 80% of uh
winning poker hands are not the highest
ranked hand mhm so you can be given the
dirt but if you play it smart you you
figure it out you can come out on top of
everybody else you know Tim I don't play
poker but I remember watching 60 Minutes
a guy named Phil Ivy who who black oh
yeah yeah he's one of the best at the
time was one maybe the maybe the best he
was being asked by the correspondent who
who was black James Brown he said how
how is it uh how how you how are you
able to deal with uh with with your race
uh as as a poker player and Phil
said poker only color that matters in
poker is green yeah and James Brown was
taken aback by that uh Dodgers were in
the World Series a few years ago and uh
mooki bets uh had done a game-winning
home run or something like that being
interviewed by another black guy named
Carol Harold carmichel I think of on
ESPN yo yo Muk everybody's talking about
this uh you're the only black player in
the in the in the World Series uh when
did you first realize that and mookie
Blake said uh
now he know what to say yeah right Phil
iy's a a legend he's one of the best
poker players now how about this new
coach for the New England
Patriots Bob Craft the owner has a press
conference to introduce him and says I
hired him because he's the best I look
for the best I hired him because he's
the best I'm from Massachusetts so okay
and
so gerod Mayo comes on he goes well you
know it's very important to have
diversity in the locker room and and
when people say I don't see color what
they really are saying is I can't see
racism so I see color just the opposite
of what his boss just said the new hello
is this thing on he just said you got
hired because you're the best now you're
saying you got hired because of Dei the
new you just under yourself the New
England Patriots had a 20year
dominating uh Dynasty and the main thing
that everybody said every week was do
your job that was the slogan every week
that was on all the gear that's what
that's what Tom Brady was saying Tom
Brady didn't get up there and talk about
how great he was he was just like you
know everybody went out there they did
their job same B belich says the same
thing do your job and this guy's like
man I can't do it I'm the wrong color
what the hell and your boss just said
the opposite he just said the opposite
he just said I hired you because you're
the best now you're saying well it's all
about making sure there's diversity in
the what also I'm just going to say like
NFL doesn't really have a diversity
problem from what I understand I mean
maybe on the coaching level is the
argument but that's not really been true
for a long time there's this there's
like a viral there's a viral tiktk video
from I think it's like a young black
woman and I think I can't remember
exactly what it was I think she's a
nurse and she said how to tell that
you're the diversity higher and then
she's like they never invite you to
meetings but they keep asking you to do
photo shoots for their
brochures but I I and she like holds it
up something something like that I don't
know but what you end up with with these
policies and uh you know Charlie Kirk
was talking about this you you you get
people in high positions of these
companies who will hire someone to put
them in a in a closet somewhere
figuratively like just put hire them
shuffle them off and then write down on
your California Dei report you've got
10% black people or whatever M and and
it's just like they they look at it not
as I'm going to hire this person for a
job they're looking at like every year
we have to spend x amount of dollars to
satisfy our diversity requirements so
they end up with people who just sit
there or people who are not competent
and if they're not competent then you
have to lower your evaluation standards
in order to justify why you hired them
in which case the product becomes
inferior the service becomes inferior
you're not helping anybody we have a
proposition in California in the '90s
called 209 which made it illegal to use
race as a factor for college admissions
and for hiring and for Contracting and
all these left-wing people said when you
do this uh blacks won't be able to get
into UC Berkeley and UCLA uh because of
race based preferences being being
eliminated and it is true got it got
passed and there were fewer blacks
admitted into UC Berkeley and fewer
blacks admitted into uh UCLA however
they were admitted at UC Irvine UC
Riverside the less competitive campuses
and were more likely to graduate on time
without student debt which shows you
that the people that you thought were
benefiting were not were in fact fact
not being benefited they were being hurt
did and the they tried to repeal this
they tried to repeal it and even
leftwing California LA Times endorsed
the repeal even leftwing California kept
it in a friend of mine who was a
celebrity uh was posting on Instagram in
support of repealing this and so and by
the way that the the repealing side out
spent the non- repealing side 10 to one
and still lost so I had an interesting
conversation with my very Lefty
Hollywood uh actress friend and uh
posting on Instagram supporting the
repealing of this which would allow
racial discrimination in in public
Contracting education and a few other
places and I I I said to her I said uh
what what percentage of you know
California is white do you know you know
the number probably about 40 45% 6.5%
black um maybe another 9% or so is uh is
Asian and then the rest are hisan 40 40%
and so I got him I good I was going to
say got him I good I mean especially
considering you were running but uh I
was like so you you're proposing that
California make
it legal
for public Contracting and schools to
discrimin on the basis of race and she's
like yes and I was like and the largest
racial demographic in California is
white people yes I said do you think
that all of these white people will just
and I said do you think white people are
racist she goes yes and I said so you
think the 40% of white people who have
political uh uh who who who politically
dominate certain areas you think they'll
decide after this law is repealed to be
less racist she's like no and I'm like
so is it possible then in say a city
where it is 80% white when they're
having elections or or or when they're
putting up public jobs or schooling they
put up signs saying whites only she's
like yeah and I'm like why would you
want that to be the case and she she
didn't real I don't know and I'm like
listen how about we all just agree we do
not want anyone to judge or ban or
anybody because of race and just pick
the person they think should have the
job shocking yeah Chris Matthews had a
show on MSNBC for a long time and one
time in an unguarded moment he said you
know most white people run down his leg
Yeah that's same most white people would
not vote for a white person if they
thought he was racist he even said that
yeah in in California roughly it's about
uh maybe six 6% or so percent uh black
about 9 or 10% uh Asian and the rest is
split between whites and uh and
Hispanics so the police department
exactly reflects the demographic of Los
Angeles yeah when something goes down if
a white cop shooting a black person or
Hispanic same activist come out starts
screaming systemic racism so it didn't
even matter during the OJ Simpson case
the the the chief of police was black
man we had backtack black police Chiefs
in he did a study during this is during
the trial to find out if anybody did
anything with the evidence tampering it
found out nobody did anything wrong
report came out it didn't matter black
police chief didn't matter I met uh I
met this uh Lefty black activist in New
York 10 years ago and he said something
really interesting to me I asked him if
he thought Donald Trump was racist I was
like do you really think Trump is racist
he's like oh yeah of course and I was
like really then and he goes yeah and
he's the least racist president we've
ever had and I was like wait a minute
and he's like oh come on he's like we've
had presidents who've owned slaves Trump
is the least racist president we've ever
had and I was like that's actually a
really interesting point I mean if if
you want to say that like everybody has
their own biases and there and there are
people that are you know everyone like
that are like more selective to their
own people that are their own color that
kind of stuff is is almost like
self-evident to some degree like like
people the just kind of like you see
people end up like they they move to the
same neighborhoods with people like them
that and you know they it's that's just
the way people are um but does and if
you want to call that racism that might
be might be everybody under under Trump
best economy ever for black people uh he
expanded so-called Enterprise zones to
lower taxes and regulations in certain
distressed areas to improve the economy
for black people he supports school
choice which is what the majority of
black and brown people living in the
inner city support the Democrats party
does not but he does he secured the
borders the person most hurt by by by
legal aliens are unskilled black people
in the UN City you have to compete
against them for jobs there was a study
done by the Civil Rights Commission a
few years ago that said a million fewer
blacks are working would otherwise be
the case but for the presence of illegal
aliens and illegal alien labor puts
downward pressure to the tune of almost
$2,000 per year on the salaries of
people living in the inner city he
pardoned Jack Johnson the first black
heavyweight champion who was who was
imprisoned for violating the so-called
man act I.E he brought white women
across state lines for for sex W Stone
in jail for that and Ken Burns the Lefty
and and Sylvester Stallone both lobbied
George W bush and Barack Obama departing
this guy neither neither of them did
Donald Trump did Donald Trump commuted
the sentence of a woman named Alice
Johnson who had a very long uh uh
sentence in uh in jail for imprisoned
for a non-violent U uh drug offense and
he signed the first step act which
allowed turn out about four or 5,000
mostly black people to have their
sentences reduced an average of 70 uh uh
months per per uh per prisoner if this
dude is RA racist he needs to go back to
racism school I mean where is in New
York you know he need to take some
medial courses or I think racism school
is probably Berkeley probably but Larry
Joe Biden had the very first Chief
diversity and inclusion officer in the
white house so obviously he's less
racist clearly you mentioned something
and speaking of Joe B this guy has lied
about his so-called civil rights record
for decades you know I I grew up in the
black church people in the black church
there in question said we never saw him
I I desegregated movie theaters and
restaurants in Wilmington Delaware even
the New York Times said there's no
evidence at all and that his AIDS quote
gently reminded him to stop saying it
Biden kept saying it anyway I was with
Andy young we tried to visit Nelson
Mandel we got arrested Andy young said
no he
didn't he just makes stuff up constantly
and it's almost it's almost impressive
because it's getting more and more
Brazen all the time even though we have
the Internet it's way easier to fact
check amazing remember his first wife
and young daughter were tragically
killed in a car accident
and Joe Biden said the man who shot who
who uh drove the truck that killed my my
wife and my daughter was drunk and that
wasn't true no evidence at all the man
was drunk moreover the evidence suggests
that his wife was one at fault the man
who investigated it at the time became a
judge and he said there's no evidence
that this man was drunk the man's
daughter came to Joe Biden and said
would you please stop saying this my
father feels guilty as as hell already
and and Joe Biden said you're right I'm
sorry I shouldn't have said it and said
it again yeah and at the time he had I
mean he had so much media attention on
him right he was the Senate Senator uh
and he had these young children he was
just tragic like he knew he was ruining
this person's life to make himself sound
more sympathetic and did it again and
again and again I mean that's true with
all of this right he does things to make
himself seem palatable to make himself
seem sympathetic to the cause that he's
courting so with all of his stories
about being a civil rights activist it's
to say to minority people oh no I I help
you and I see your causes but he doesn't
actually do anything he puts in this uh
Chief diversity officer this is I have
my mind because this person resigned
today after three years on the job just
to say look I am the most diverse person
I am the person who encourages uh uh
diverse hiring in the White House no one
did this before me and it's so if he
doesn't win the election when Trump is
reelected for him to say well Trump
doesn't have a chief diversity officer
even though I specifically created this
he goes on Charlamagne the God and says
you ain't really black unless you know
whether you want to vote for me or vote
for Donald Trump this who does that it's
crazy it's the most arrogant and to me
racist thing of all time because what
he's saying is I don't actually care
about anything that affects you I just
want you to be dumb enough to vote for
me on nothing the policies that the left
wants don't do what the polic what the
left says the policies will do so right
off the bat if you're arguing for
leftist policies you are lying yes but
if you're Joe Biden you're not only
arguing for bad policies you're just
making stuff up right he does but like
the the economic policies that the the
left wants they produce poverty they
they disincentivize Enterprise They
disincentivize people from working I I I
was going to read a note but I got to I
got a comment now because there's there
was there's a viral clip of this guy
named uh Professor Richard wolf who has
to be one of the most disingenuous or
stupid professors we I've ever had the
displeasure of having to listen to and
he has this viral lecture he does people
were retweeting it it you know was
getting 100,000 views and said this is
required learning for every school what
does he say he does this bit where he
goes if you're going to be hired by an
employer let's say you you negotiate
whatever and he says I'll pay you $20 an
hour you have to produce more than $20
of value per hour in order for him to
hire you so at the end of the day if you
feel like you're being ripped off it's
because you are and it's just like a
5-year-old came up with this yeah a f
like a 5-year-old came up with the idea
that so so I did I I earlier today I
recorded like a half an hour breakdown
of just everything wrong with it and
it's funny because I'm probably like my
audience the people who watch my my
Clips in the morning probably know even
more about it than I do because they run
businesses and they have jobs but I was
like let's invert this let's invert the
proposition brought up by this Marxist
Professor because he cites Carl marks in
his argument a guy uh uh let's say Phil
wants to hire Kellen Kellen is going to
produce
widgets so Phil says you make widgets
for me I pay 20 bucks an hour K says I
can make one widget per hour Phil says
okay Phil then has to run the pay pay
the taxes manage the business source the
materials for the widget production and
then figure out how to sell the widget
so Phil does all of that Phil ends up
getting paid $5 he sells the widget for
$25 so that extra $5 value goes in his
pocket for what he's doing let's invert
the proposition my response to this guy
would be I got an idea if someone if I
wanted to hire someone to make uh uh you
know widgets let's say skateboards and
they said I can make one skateboard per
hour for 50 bucks I but but I know that
you're going to get $10 extra in my
labor because I'm a Marxist who listens
to this Lefty guy so I refuse I'm worth
more than that I say okay let's make a
different deal you make the skateboard
and then pay me to sell them how much do
you want to pay me to do your
sales what do you mean I how much are
you going to pay me to do the sales work
for you so now you pick up the
managerial stuff you pick up the
regulatory work you pick up insurance or
whatever it is you need you Source the
materials you pay for all that then you
bring me the skateboard I will sell it
for you and I'll take 20% of the sales
you get to own the means of production
congratulations all all the only the the
only issue at hand with the proposition
of an employer an employee is who is
accepting risk and who is not because
you could flip employer and employee in
any direction and the only that matters
is who assumes the risk guaranteeing a
salary to someone to make a product
means they don't got to think about it
they don't got to worry about it they
get paid a flat rate and they can go
home and cash that cash that check but
if Phil ends up paying for a 100 widgets
and cannot sell them he's bankrupt he
loses everything and he can't buy dinner
well the guy also loses his job that's
true yeah
eventually you got to make a profit
right but it's but it's it's which is
also why Tim the the the minimum wage
and and people that left love the back
it up hurts the very people who are
unskilled because you're requiring
somebody to pay for something you can't
do you can't produce and uh Milton
Freeman said the minimum wage law is
perhaps the most quote anti-negro law in
the statute books close at one time a
black teenager was more likely to be
employed than a white teenager now in
the inner city you find 50% unemployment
for people looking for jobs largely
because the minimum wage has priced them
out of competition you're not able to
produce $15 worth of stuff so why should
I pay $15 you're not going to work about
six years ago six or seven years ago I
was I had a meeting with an accountant
to you know start picking up accounting
work for us and Company was much smaller
but I don't think they had any employees
so uh New Jersey had had awn the books
where the minimum wage was increasing a
set amount over a period of time and he
told me that they lost I think 30% of
their customers in the uh latest uh
minimum wage increase right and uh he
was like so obviously we as an
accounting firm like weird we're
actually taking a hit we're going to
have to lay some people off the reason
we uh lost 30% of our clients is because
they went out of business overnight he's
like what you got to understand is if
they say they're increasing the hourly
rate of say like server staff from $10
to $11 an hour they want to do it slowly
so they say you know 10 to 1050 now it's
going from 1050 to 11 the people who are
running these small diners the people
who are who who have you know you know a
small restaurant or a pizza place or
it's you know um maybe an antique store
or something they're on razor thin
margins in a tough economy and they're
not paying themselves as much as they
pay out in labor one day the dial gets
clicked over and now they have to find
30% more in wages so either they
increase the prices which causes a
customer shock they don't get as many
customers in because the customers don't
have the money to pay the increase right
overnight he's like within a SP of a few
months one by one they fall down like
dominoes and they say thank you for
everything you've done for us but we're
closing the doors there was a study
about New Jersey and Pennsylvania this
is in the 90s and one state raised the
minimum wage the other one didn't so it
gave you an ideal laboratory to find out
what's going to happen and according to
these these two professors they're named
for card and Krueger the state that
raised the minimum wage had an increase
in jobs relative to the state that did
not which refuted probably years of
study about the minimum wage and so Bill
Clinton and the other Democrats began
touting this study because it justifies
raising the minimum wage however other
economists try to replicate the results
and instead of asking employers did you
raise uh did you hire people or not hire
people they asked for payroll cards to
confirm it and and turned out the state
that raised minimum wage lost job Rel to
the state that did not just the opposite
of what the leftwing economist said and
by the way just before you respond don't
forget make an announcement right here
in the Tim pool show the Tim cast I'm
giving away free copies of hold it up of
as goes California to everybody who
opens up an Old Glory bank account on
which I am co-founder and member the
board of directors open account on ol
Glory
bank.com and when you get your Old Glory
Bank card activate it and you do that
you will get a free copy of AD schs
California my mission to rescue the
Golden State and save the nation it's a
$25 value oldglory bank.com open an
account take you eight minutes to do it
activate your Old Glory debit card when
you get it in the mail and you get a
free copy of Asos California well we're
going to go to Super Chat so if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and head over to
timcast.net I spoke with Tom McDonald
and the daily wire crew and I told them
uh I'm going to go to facts with uh uh
what is it okay I got to make sure it's
facts with Ben right make sure because I
we just got the URL FS yes like fact
don't care about your feelings so it's
facts withth ben.com and you click
purchase you buy Tom McDonald and Ben
Shapiro's new song Facts it's got a
great message and Ben Shapiro is rapping
in it Ben Shapiro in the past what did
he say he rap wasn't music or something
like that he said something that
something like that and he's a
classically trained violinist he is and
and his his Twitter Troll game has been
A+ where he was like thank you to my
parents for sending me to a classical
violin school for 15 years or whatever
so I could be the number one rapper in
America he's currently money well spent
yes he's number one on iTunes Tom
McDonald and and uh Ben are both number
one on iTunes which is in the world I'm
pretty sure but let's be real iTunes is
not the main place where everything's at
so while it is a good metric and it does
beat out a lot of the industry because
they've they've they've lost interest in
being a nobody want nobody will buy
their music so they just give up on it
we can still sell music this way when
you buy on Amazon or iTunes these are
the it's it's a dirty game but it's the
only way they actually track for the
Billboard charts if by next Thursday at
11:59 p.m. we can amass a large amount
of sales for Tom mdon and Ben chapiro
I'm hoping we weren't we weren't able to
pull it off because they played I I I
feel like we got shafted we did together
again with the daily wire and they said
our sales did not count because they
changed the reporting met wow so
naturally this pisses me off this feels
to me like an opportunity for success
and revenge because it's not our song
they're not paying us promote in any way
anything you buy will go to likely Tom
McDonald but I would I would love and I
I know many of you would to see Ben
Shapiro on the Billboard Hot 100 as one
of the top rappers in the world and uh
it's possible if y'all go out and buy
their song and want to spend that $129
and uh you know I I I hope you do if you
can if you can't don't worry about it
but you know I would love to see that I
also would love to see my book get on
the New York Times best selling list
because on your show so please go to
Amazon or Barnes and Noble in order as
goes California let's get that on the
New York Times bestseller list shove it
in their faces uh let's go let's go if
if if we can I I would love to say wow
Larry got a number one near time but you
do know it's editorial right like they
play games with I know I know they play
games I mean but let be billboard does
too like yeah Tom made a a video Tom
McDonald made a video about it it seems
like every time he's about to correct
some major Milestone they go o whoopsie
we can't you know for this reason and so
it is an uphill battle but understand
everybody we are trying to storm the
gates of the woke institutions and
they're not happy about it so they're
trying to find every way imaginable to
stop us but I just I just would love to
wake up not next week Tuesday but the
following Tuesday when the billboard
comes out and Ben Shapiro is one of the
top rappers in the world on the Hot 100
which is the the list that that'll be
amazing I think they'll be number one
sales I think they I here here's what I
think is going to happen based on the
size of Tom's audience you know us doing
a push for it and daily wire I think
it's possible that Ben and Tom could
reach number one on the hip-hop charts
Hot 100 however that's tough I do think
if everybody you know who watched our
shows and their shows because this is
this is a massive audience especially
with Tom I think it's possible they
reach like 75 Hot 100 wow but and
because at that point you need like 30
million streams and which is which is
you're you're going to need like um 50
to 100K sales tough tough tough tough
hit number one Hot 100 they would need I
think probably like 500,000 sales but I
would just man I don't think it's going
to happen but Ben Shapiro getting a gold
record for rapping that would just be
amazing anyway we your super chats we
were your super chats all right here we
go Chris Lambert says two days in a row
uh this news on Texas ain't going to be
stopping anytime soon M triple flip says
on mass is pronounced on mass please
guys please well
okay here we go I'm not your buddy guy
he's returned he says can you hear that
drums in the distance Drums of War now
it comes down to those with the
temperament of a toddler and those who
seek the West destruction versus those
who refuse enslavement who shall win
there was a story we didn't get to but
there's rumors that um private militia
groups are making their way down to
Texas that's what I've heard and you
know I can only say this I'm not going
to tell anybody what they can or can't
do in a free country where you're free
to move around do whatever you want my
opinion is anybody not involved in Texas
law enforcement who is not ordered by
the their their uh superiors to be down
there you stay away from it not for for
for safety's reasons but
also I'm worried someone's going to like
get in the way of Greg Abbott at at a
very crucial moment not that Greg Abbott
is a perfect guy his record is not
perfect but you know imagine you've got
the top athlete you know they're playing
in tennis don't run out on the court
thinking you're going to help you may
just Jam things up and right now the
most important thing for all of us is a
a a legitimate legal resolution on the
issue of the states having a right to
defend its borders what GRE Greg Abbott
is doing is within the law what Joe
Biden is doing is outside the law if
random people show up and start getting
in the way of Abbott it muddies it and
actually puts Texas in Mercer territory
let's take the legal High Ground on this
one because we're winning but again
again you know but as I said at the
beginning of your show uh this is on Joe
Biden right Joe Biden has caused all of
this and hopefully there there'll be no
violence hopefully there'll be no civil
unrest but it's on Joe Biden he caused
this and did it on purpose there was a
statement released by Biden today or
tonight uh while we're during the show
about something that they have planned
for the B the Border but I didn't read
the whole thing um so the real eff and
deal says what event do you think future
historians will recall as the first step
of the American Civil War of the second
American Civil War well it's interesting
it's it's very interesting because uh
when you look at the history of the
United States leading up to the Civil
War it's it it's it's it's it could be
reduced at infinum uh in the 1820s there
was discussion of Civil War for the
issue of slavery and nothing happened
for 40 years you some people might argue
that the definitive moment was the
election of Abraham Lincoln because uh
several states seceded from the Union
before he was even inaugurated and so
that secession led to fighting typically
we think the War itself started with
Fort Sumpter but Bleeding Kansas had
been happening for seven years prior
where you literally had abolitionist and
pro slavery forces going to these states
and fighting because like literally
killing each other because they wanted
new slave territories or uh you know
free states I think it's fair to say the
Civil Bleeding Kansas was Civil War it's
just not actual Civil War in New York or
Maryland or or you know Pennsylvania or
whatever not that went anything went to
New York for instance but the idea idea
that armed ideological factions from the
North and the South were going to new
territories and fighting over it is is
that not a component of the Civil War
it's only that when it drew in all the
other states were like this is when the
Civil War started so that being said if
history if we're basing it off of what
history currently goes by you would need
an Eagle pass you they would it would
need to be an Eagle pass the moment when
the federal government came there and
said it's our jurisdiction back off the
state said you are in violation of
codified law no and then Fort Sumpter
was not a legitimate battle nobody was
trying to kill each other only one guy
died I think it was by an
accident Eagle Pass could be a moment
where border patrol agents order
National Guard to drop their weapons the
the border patrol says back up no you
drop your weapons and then we get we
hear shots fired nobody's injured what
would happen if uh National Guard or CBP
engage in a conflict where shots are
fired fired nobody knows who shot first
nobody gets injured nobody dies we'd say
wow crisis averted 100 years later
they'd say the first battle of the
second Civil War Eagle Pass just like
Fort Suter so I believe you would need
an Eagle pass type moment and what we
would look at is all of the fighting
we've seen in Portland and Washington
The Summer of Love riots are effectively
The Bleeding Kansas the stop cop City
riots January 6 people would refer to
that as our civil Strife period much
like Bleeding Kansas was an Eagle pass I
hope not but something like Eagle Pass
would be that that shot Hur around the
world the Constitution gives the uh
government limited duties and powers and
obligations one of them specifically is
the borders specifically is immigration
question is when the federal government
is not doing its job on that issue is it
okay for the states affected to do to do
it for them and I think the answer is
yes but when they're not doing their job
and they're not when Congress is not
stopping this and they're not
it seems to me that the states have an
obligation to defend their border and I
and I like what what uh what the
governor of Texas is doing as s Spartan
makes an a very good point he says we
are in Schrodinger Civil War depending
on what happens we're either in the
Civil War or not and he's completely
right if what happens in Eagle Pass
dissolves with no there there's there
was talk I was going to say there a talk
of a senate deal on the border which is
basically Texas giving up like they
they're talking about thousands of
people per day to be allowed in if this
is the deal so let's say everybody just
chills out pulls their people back the
border is secure whatever no no conflict
no crisis
happens nobody's going to say Civil War
started however when when we are finally
at the point hopefully not but if we
ever get to the point where there are
National Guardsmen shooting at federal
law
enforcement history will look back and
say the Civil War started a long time
ago like Fort Sumter this is the this is
the point that I was making even though
we historically look back and say the
Civil War started at Fort Suter the
people still were at the Battle of First
Battle of BU run thinking there was no
Civil War they were already in it they
didn't know and so fair point if
tomorrow Joe Biden says I hereby resign
I'm done I leave I give up everything
kamla Harris fumbles and bumbles and
then everything just stops states start
cleaning things up the Federal
Government stops doing everything the
doj stops going after Trump trump gets
elected comes in cleans things up no
Civil War ever happened
nothing that's an ideal scenario I
guess yeah it's like what if no one died
at Fort Suter you know what would have
happened well nobody was killed in the
battle well it was an accident right
yeah but that's like we don't consider
that like they weren't trying to kill
each other they were just like hey you
know and it wasn't until the Battle of
ball run they were like time time to go
uh Joseph Kush says Putin just signed a
decree Rec in recognition of the
Republic of Texas can someone fact check
that that sounds like it's not true
sounds like it's not true right but I I
definitely wanted to read that one and
say like someone Google that it actually
sounds like something Putin would do do
to troll America Kan Abel says while we
are in Civil War II started by Dems
China will invade Taiwan starting an
official World War I I think we are
doomed to repeat everything again I
support Texas I think there's a strong
likelihood that uh our adversaries uh
particularly the bricks nations are
fomenting civil war in this country so
that when they make their moves it
prevents World War III when China moves
onto Taiwan there will not be a World
War III because the United States will
be too busy fighting itself and so they
get their regional conflict Venezuela
gets their regional conflict Iran gets
their regional conflict and all the
regional conflicts are the world at war
but without us intervention it's not
going to be as pronounced it's not going
to be as widespread and the US will
eventually fall apart well most people
in Taiwan don't believe that the us is
going to come to the support in the
event that Taiwan is invaded anyway uh
because of the way Gavin pulled out of
Gavin the way Joe Biden pulled out of
Afghanistan and the thing about that Tim
is not only did he pull out not only did
he leave $7 billion worth of uh military
equipment not only were 13 Personnel uh
service members killed and we left
behind hundreds of Americans and uh
Afghan collaborators he publicly said
Joe Biden did that nobody advised him
that the Taliban would come back and the
Afghan government would collapse two
generals testified under oath that's
exactly the advice that he was given so
if you're a friend or a foe of America
either our military is so incompetent
they did not see this coming or they
gave Joe Biden competent advice and the
commander-in chief was so incompetent he
didn't follow it either way not good I
want to read this super that just came
in I don't see anything under news about
Putin probably not true no ra gidick
says former fed gs15 here I quited 39
years old it is corrupt and I couldn't
affect it no matter what I did how high
I got nothing changed money wasted and
citizens abused CBP should quit Nazi
camp guards just followed orders too
Bravo sir Bravo sir for uh uh you know
for for standing up and doing the right
thing man yeah I I think regardless of
what CBP are saying there's there's not
going to be a circumstance where someone
comes up to me in the street and says oh
I'm with the CBP I'm a big fan I'm going
to be like you need to go make a
statement like like you you can't work
for an organization doing this look I'll
make the point have people quit yes have
they oh yeah yeah a lot of a lot of them
have what Pretenders do you have any
idea I don't know about any hard numbers
we just heard anecdotes of people being
like I'm not doing this and they're and
they're quitting but some people are
just staying and I know it's difficult I
I don't care look people say oh Tim says
quit your job blah blah dude I'm saying
if if they're doing things that like are
destroying this country I am not saying
sacrifice your job if you're scared to
say you support Trump I'm saying you
should say you support Trump because if
everybody did then there would be no
concern no fear and they couldn't do
anything about it you don't need to lose
your job over this I'm just saying stand
up for yourself speak up for what you
believe in it's a nuanced position but
if you're a human Smuggler dude I just
well I'm not a human Smuggler I just
work for the I work up here I'm like guy
your organization is smuggling humans if
you're a CBP agent in West Virginia
understand that the resources you
provide and the infrastructure around
you facilitates that even in the
slightest degree there was uh in
Ohio uh it was I believe ice brought a
bunch of illegal immigrants to a police
station and said we need these guys held
temporarily so that we can then in the
morning get transport to dep portum and
the the sheriff was like you got it boss
the next day ice was gone and they were
just like what what is this we have a
bunch of illegal immigrants sitting here
so they released them right onto the
street of where they live I'm sorry man
that's happening in California talked
about it in my book because it's a
sanctuary State yep uh and they will not
allow ice to take these people many of
the whom have come to the country
several times illegally and have them
deported I'll tell you I'll tell you
this right now let's let's let's be
reasonable as we can if you're a CBP
agent you should be in protest to your
superiors like what's going on I don't
want to be party to this more
importantly if you are at the border
should say hey man I'm not going to do
that I'm not going to facilitate the
Smugglers the cartels are bringing
people up for thousands of dollars and
then the only way that's possible is
because the cartel knows they can do a
handoff with Customs and Border
Protection if there was no CBP there to
accept them and the policy was rejection
the coyotes and the cartels would have
no business at all because they'd be
like yeah PS will get you up to the
Border where there's a fence the
National Guard and you can't get in
they'd be like I'm not paying you the
cartel
I think it was like a billion do off of
the human smuggling it works both way
the cartels wouldn't offer it and also
people wouldn't seek it out because they
know the border is closed one of the
stats that always uh comes up is uh how
many people on the FBI's Most Wanted
like the terrorist watch list have come
to the border and people will point out
that far fewer came under Trump than
those who have arrived under Biden and
it's because under Biden they know
they're much more likely to get in that
seems uh like an obvious show that no
one takes our border security seriously
if people who are on identified
terrorists are like I'll just risk it
I'll see if I can get through because
they probably can that is really bad
well when you're releasing people into
the interior and giving them a court
date it's a joke and they're not going
to show up it's a joke yeah and Asylum
90% of them are here for for jobs by
definition that does not make you
eligible for asy no they just go to
states where they can get driver's
license and stuff like that and then
just live essentially a normal life BS
production says what happened to
yesterday's episode 947 it is up in its
full 2 hours and 20 minutes on Rumble so
go to Rumble uh timcast IRL subscribe to
our Rumble Channel and uh it is there uh
to keep it simple there are there there
are rules that are Universal that apply
to rumble YouTube and X where if certain
things that I can't repeat are said then
I've been told explicitly by you know
people working these companies the show
gets taken out there can do about it and
so these have to do with legal liability
criminal liability and things like that
so uh in terms of last night's episode
it just got to that point and then what
we did did was we put it to the members
only why do we do that it's fast easy
it's already set up and then once it's
done immediately the show is in full
available on all podcast platforms and
Rumble and the offending you know issue
is snipped out of the show so that's it
for the future we're going to do what
every other television station does when
these things happen and that's a dump
button Fox News has it CNN had they
historically all have it it's not really
been an element of the podcasting world
but I will tell you a one of the big
reasons why a lot of your favorite
podcasts stopped going live started
switching to either premieres or
pre-recorded was because of this issue
that you can't control some like people
are hanging out they're talking for a
few hours someone says something off the
cuff they don't realize what they
actually said and there's nothing we can
do about it but with the dump button
click 7 Seconds deleted and no one
none's the wiser right so it's it's it's
a shame that's the world we live in but
unless you're hanging out in someone's
house there's no platform that can
support certain things being said so I
want to stress this everybody was like
you should stream on Rumble I've already
talked to rumble about it Rumble said
yeah we we have no choice but take you
down if the same thing was said and I'm
like I know right so we we did put the
episode on Rumble you can watch it there
it is available and iTunes Spotify
Etc Let's uh let's grab some more Super
chats Guardsman norheim says Richard
wolf talks and his facial expressions
mimic mimicking every Disney villain
it's very off-putting why would anyone
trust someone who acts like that it's
just it's really funny because he did
this interview uh with Abby Martin and
that so this is viral clip the audio is
not normalized well but he he uh
reiterates his point in interview with
Abby Martin and they're both just
smirking and I'm like I mean come on
like Abby and him are smart people
there's no way you research the issue of
economics and ignore the fact that most
businesses are small even larger
businesses CEOs do a lot of work it is
this weird world where you have all of
these leftists who genuinely believe
CEOs don't do anything I mean to be fair
Jack dorsy probably didn't do anything
when he was a CEO of Twitter but the
question then is like what's his comp
compensation and what value is providing
to a
system the these people do not
understand how difficult it is to pay
right so the legality of let let me put
this way I remember the first time I was
like wow I'm making a lot of money I'd
like to give my mom stuff and my
account's like oh that's illegal I was
like what I was like I can't like you
know give my no there's Federal limit on
how much you can money you can give
someone per year and then you've got to
pay extra money or income tax and Stu
like oh okay okay well hold on we won't
do that then it's called gift tax gift
tax and there's there's limits and uh uh
okay but you could theoretically just
give someone any amount of money but
then it's all taxed and I'm like okay
well so that that is possible you can't
just pay people uh you can't give
anybody you want a job if if I hire
someone I have to create a a a
legitimate C like written out
explanation of what their job is and why
they're getting paid and it has to be on
record for our accounting why because
rich people in the past have like hired
their son and paid them a lot of money
and then the iris is like you're just
trying to gift your kid money you can't
do that so now we have to actually have
on record in the event of an audit
here's the person here's their job
here's their expectation here are their
hours here's what they do it's wild and
so these people these leftists think
CEOs literally do nothing don't get me
wrong slum Lords exist and there are
corrupt people but the idea that because
there's a corrupt individual and a
criminal that means all of capitalism is
bad is just you're being manipulated by
crackpots like this Richard wolf guy
well you can give away your money but
the recipient has to pay a gift tax
right and it actually gets pretty
exorbitant and then it becomes
prohibitive so my my point there is but
it's your money you can give it away but
let's clarify that I you cannot you
cannot write a check to someone and say
Here's money for you the government goes
wait if you want to do that I get a I
get a substantial portion of it so the
the literal the literal sense is I
cannot give a family member money I have
to ask the government for permission ask
the government how much of the money
they get before the transaction is
completed so you can technically give a
family member money so long as you pay
the government 30% well well the reason
however that most people have this
attitude about people who run businesses
and and own them is said they never run
a hot dog stand they never met a payroll
no idea how difficult it is I I had I
had a we made Kool-Aid when I was like
seven years old my my dad said I'm gonna
give I'm gonna I'm gonna give you what
30 bucks so you can go get the materials
you need to make Kool-Aid and go sell it
at the baseball game but you've got to
pay me back my investment and so me and
my brother we made this big we had this
picture was a pump we went around with
Little Dixie Cups and we sold them for
like a little bit of money and we came
back we paid my dad back and we had
money for candy and that was you know my
dad teaching me that stuff somebody once
said that a CEO of a corporation is like
a duck on a pond calm on the surface but
paddling like hell underneath yeah now I
think it was Claud Dean gay who said
that oh was it no of course not my point
is is here let's let's be asch as as
literal as possible it is not legal for
you to give a per a person money it is
legal to give a person and the
government money that's that's the
reality of it put unreal yeah right you
have to crazy they made the system they
benefit from but but the government is
not without Grace you are allowed I
think right now I think the limit is
$15,000 so no you can't buy a house for
a family member that's not a real thing
you can buy a house for a family member
and give the government a third of the
cost of the
house it's so gross right so like let's
put it this way let's say you wanted to
buy a house for your mom and it cost
$250,000 you do that that your your mom
would have to pay the government 30 or
whatever percent of the value of the
house in taxes so how could the family
member actually accept a gift of that of
that magnitude they cannot so while it
is technically possible for you to hand
them a check not a so you would have to
calculate the cost of taxes and how it
was to to get to 250 write a check for
that amount family member then pays the
government their share of the gift you
are giving a family member and then your
family member can buy a
house there you go welcome to uh why so
many people think taxation is well
that's one of the reasons why the uh uh
that player Otani got so much money
because of the state income tax in
California
13.3% oh that's right High tax in the in
the country uh 1% of it is um a
Millionaire's tax for mental illness so
13.3% highest state income tax in the
country and it New York city has the
highest taxation in the country but only
because New York City itself has an
income tax so you've got state city and
federal if you live in New York City and
that's so what happens is a bunch of
ultra Rich New Yorkers try to spend half
the year in Florida right New York
started going after them now here's a
secret if you're super wealthy you spend
half the year in Puerto Rico then you
pay no income tax no federal income tax
and that's intentional it better be half
a year because they check that yes they
do one day one day the wrong way you're
in trouble and it's intentional though
they want you down there spending money
to help build up the infrastructure and
the economy of Puerto Rico so they're
saying hey look we're GNA we're going to
tell you this you you're you're a
millionaire you're going to spend a
million bucks a year in taxes keep it
but you got to live in Puerto Rico six
six months in one day because then
you're going to be spending that money
in Puerto Rico and that's why we're
letting you keep it so taxation they use
as a way to manipulate and social
engineer that's why they put a tax on
cigarettes they put a tax on gas they
put a tax on soda pop
they want to manipulate your behavior
and I think that that is unconstitution
and they want to raise money for that
crazy Bureau bureaucracy that they have
all these government workers who are
being overpaid paying more than they
they would get at private sector in a
similar job they got to pay for him all
right Trish Barry says it's my son Wes's
birthday he got me watching the show
born in 97 jenz son with Boomer mom
members and cast Brew drinkers High
Larry fan since KABC days wow shout out
790 KABC happy birthday man that's cool
yeah right on thanks for watching happy
for there good job converting your mom
to
IRL it's the young people man leaders
Future
Leaders all right there's YouTube has
always given me the the business these
past few days it's like the browser is
half Frozen it's weird don't know what
the problem
is all right Kurt Crowley says to Kill a
Mocking Bird has polluted some of the
thought process the time setting was in
the 1930s however people read it and
digest it still think we are in that
time frame right yeah great movie too
awesome
movie Greg pick Don Brown says I voted
for Larry they changed it news scum is
filth a lot of people said that that
their votes were changed that's crazy a
lot of people told me I've but we've
heard we heard a lot about that over the
past few years of people posting being
like hey I I checked my thing and it was
the wrong one and it's just so dirty man
creepy
stuff all right Ian says I want to bring
up to Mr Elder that the nberg trials
clearly stated that following orders was
not a valid excuse for committing crimes
I think you agree with me early on you
said that was a good point well yeah and
uh it's not like uh the border patrol
however is killing
Jews yeah they're just facilitating one
of the largest human smuggling
operations and so and and I'm not to
downplay Holocaust my point was I do
believe what CBP is facilitating is
probably the lowest tier of human rights
violations and like atrocities MH the
highest of course being like genocide
and Holocaust but what's the like you've
opened the door to atrocities it's
facilitating what the cartels are doing
there are young girls being raped every
single day in large numbers it's
disgusting uh we were talking I was
talking to the guys from uh uh uh one a
couple guys from Texas this morning
talking about how there's like used
condoms and just filth
everywhere these these these cartels are
only able to do this because CBP is
standing there waiting with smiles on
their faces and open arm saying we got
it from here buddies so all of these
crimes against humanity that are
occurring would stop if CBP simply said
we will not facilitate this instead what
they're saying well they allow it to
happen there was an interview where CBP
guy says they keep allowing them in and
the the guy doing the interview says
it's kind of strange because to the
average Observer it's CBP that is
allowing them in and putting them in
cars and driving them to to their
destinations if CBP said you will not
you shall not pass the coyotes would be
like we're we're we're dead in the water
we can't we can't run this business
anymore so so long as you have thousands
of people dying in the deserts drowning
in the rivers and young women being
raped repeatedly and and and some of
these are being sex trafficked and the
fentel and the Fentanyl and the deaths
I'm sorry but CBP is engaged in like an
atrocity but the lowest tier I I don't
like come on anyway tough talk my
friends if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends become a member at
timcast.net coffee to support our work
directly and you know it's the best
coffee you'll ever have or if you don't
want to support us at all go to facts
withth ben.com that's fact like facts
don't care about your feelings and buy
the song from Tom McDonald and Ben
Shapiro because then you're supporting
Tom McDonald and helping Ben Shapiro
become the top rapper in the world you
can follow the show at timcast IRL you
can follow me personally at timcast
Larry do you want to shout anything out
yeah I want you one time one more time
to mention that my book Tim told me to
hold it up higher it's called as goes
California my mission to rescue the
Golden State we've been talking a little
bit about it throughout the podcast it
is available free for people who go to
Old Glory bank.com open up an account
and when you get your Old Glory bank
debit card and activate it you will get
a free copy of this book a $25 value
there's I see andice Owens Candace Owens
did the forward right forward by Candace
Owens Candice Owens your hand was over
and yeah Andis cand I knew it sir I
wanted you to shout her out yeah did
Candace Owens uh wrote the Ford right on
thanks thanks for coming yeah it's been
awesome having you here it's good to see
you it's been my pleasure Hannah thank
you yeah U I'm Hannah Clair bmla I'm a
writer for SC r.com you guys should
follow timcast newws on Twitter and
Instagram to see all of our work I'm
really grateful to be part of that team
if you want to follow me personally I'm
on Twitter at HC brimo and I'm on
Instagram at hana. B Phil it's good to
see you cheers Larry thank you very much
for everything uh pleasure I am Phil
that remains on Twix I am Phil that
remains official on Instagram the band
is All That Remains you can follow us on
Apple music Spotify Pandora Amazon music
YouTube you know the internet and
remember the left lane is for Crime uh
good to see you again Larry you guys can
follow me at Kellen PDL and check out
all of our clips from timcast IRL all
weekend we've got culture War Clips um
ton of content goes up every weekend
check it out we will see you all next
week Monday thanks for hanging
out